la séance vient de reprendre à l'instant
c'est effectivement un rappel au
règlement de Pierre Laurent qui est en
cours on retourne dans l'hémicycle en
direct cette nuit pour accélérer la
clôture autoritaire des débats sur
l'article 7 et sur le projet de loi
retraite la commission des affaires
sociales a invoqué l'article 44 bis du
règlement pour déclarer y recevable
plusieurs centaines de sous amendements
qui ont été déposés après la réécriture
de l'article 7 qui sont devenus
subitement irrecevables alors que les
amendements qu'il reproduisaient avaient
eux étaient déclarés recevables par la
même commission la présidente de roche
sur la figure au compte-rendu a
d'ailleurs reconnu qu'il s'agissait des
mêmes amendements mais le vice-président
karucci nous a en quelque sorte livré
l'explication de texte
à partir du moment où l'article réécrit
était devenu un amendement cela rendait
soi-disant impossible de le sous-amender
en le on contestant le sens
effectivement le règlement 40
impossible au dépôt d'un sous amendement
qui soit contraire à l'amendement auquel
il s'applique mais c'est en l'occurrence
un détournement de sens du règlement car
si nous acceptons cette interprétation
il suffit alors de transformer un
article entier et ça a été le cas cette
nuit on en abondement on le réécrivant
pour le rendre inabondable c'est-à-dire
l'article qui est lui-même
constitutionnellement amendable et
contestable devient par le jeu d'une
réécriture on amendement un article
inammendable c'est donc une atteinte de
fait à la capacité et au droit
constitutionnels d'amendement des
parlementaires
il faut donc être extrêmement vigilant
mes chers collègues vers sur ce
précédent car c'est un précédent qui a
été créé et qui ouvre la porte à toutes
les manipulations contre le droit
d'amendement et jeudi au public merci
assumez le vote du coup
[Applaudissements]
le président mon rappel au règlement se
fonde sur l'article 44 de la
Constitution les membres du Parlement et
le gouvernement ont le droit
d'amendement cette nuit en effet des
sous amendements ont été déclarés
irrecevables sans même avoir été examiné
en commission de la veut même de sa
présidente nombre des nôtres portés sur
des précisions techniques manifestement
parfaitement recevable ce droit
inaliénable d'amendement a été utilisé
par la commission pour reformuler
l'article 7 dans une version quasi
identique au texte originel dans le seul
but de faire disparaître les amendements
des groupes de gauche qui relaient ici
les préoccupations de nos concitoyens
mobilisés très massivement encore hier
ces amendements portés par exemple sur
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
sur le report de l'âge légal de départ
en retraite ces sujets que vous nous
disiez vouloir débattre que vraiment
entendu ici sur l'examen de ce texte à
l'Assemblée nationale mais ce qui se
passe ici même au Sénat et l'autre face
d'une même pièce empêcher le travail
parlementaire sur ce texte et cela non
non pas le Sénat où est passé la sagesse
que vous convoquez régulièrement
où est la rigueur légendaire du Sénat
disparu dans de basses manœuvres qui
n'effaceront pas nous vous le disons mes
chers collègues la détermination du
peuple français a rejeté cette réforme
et cette très très mauvaise réforme
merci chers collègues monsieur gay
[Applaudissements]
pour un rappel au règlement
merci monsieur le Président sur le même
article
je m'exprime devant vous avec solennité
mes chers collègues et une colère froide
nos débats sont très suivis à
l'extérieur beaucoup nous ont dit qu'il
comptait sur nous tous et tous pour
échanger avoir un débat de fond et pour
notre paragragoche nous y opposer pour
les faire échec car nous sommes dans
l'opposition depuis jeudi nous pensons
que nous faisons la politique en ayant
un débat argumenté précisé documenté ce
qui est bien le rôle du Parlement tant
que nous sommes pas passés à la Sixième
République et changer de constitution
chaque parlementaire a le droit de
déposer un amendement et de le défendre
même si la droite accusée la gauche
d'une obstruction cordiale et qu'en
réponse nous vous renvoyons celle d'une
obstruction
silencieuse nous avantions dans le débat
celui que nous avons eu dimanche projet
comme projet répartition contre
capitalisation a été utile je le pense
qui peut dire ici que nous avons perdu
du temps c'est pour ça que hier nous
avons été très surpris qu'au moment
d'arriver au cœur du projet vous
déclenchiez une série d'articles de
règlement pour la première fois
l'arthrite 38 reste régnant la parole
puis la réécriture de l'article 7
rendant innamendable cet article et
enfin déclarant nos amendements devenus
sous amendements
anticonstitutionnel pour question
d'égalité alors qu'une demi-heure avant
il ne l'était pas sans pourvoir nous
l'expliquer si on y rajoute les
décisions pris ce matin avec de
nouvelles dispositions pour réduire une
nouvelle fois le temps de parole c'est
un coup de force coup de force certes
permis par le règlement mais le
règlement n'est que là pour organiser
notre vie commune lorsqu'on l'utilise
pour régler une question politique c'est
que nous sommes au bord d'une crise
démocratique en fait l'utilisation de
toutes ces règles prouve votre fébrilité
et monte que vous avez besoin
d'autoritarisme pour établir votre
autorité politique vous avez perdu et
vous le savez vous êtes minoritaire
alors que chacun sera sur ici que celles
et ceux qui luttent dehors nous restons
utile et déterminé ici comme samedi
prochain pour le retrait de ce projet
monsieur symbole des
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ceci est un rappel au
règlement même arctique 44 bis en effet
le recours exceptionnel exceptionnel à
l'article 38 du Règlement Intérieur et
cela en pleine nuit le jour même d'une
mobilisation historique de grande
ampleur contre cette réforme des
retraites écrit main dans la main avec
le gouvernement nous sommes constitués
une attaque en règle et particulièrement
grave de notre démocratie parlementaire
cet article clôture en effet un débat
parlementaire d'une façon qui ne norme
pas notre institution j'ai bien entendu
madame la Première ministre tout à
l'heure qui a invoquait la séparation
des pouvoirs pourtant nous ne pouvons
que constater la constitution ou du
moins le renforcement de ce bloc de
droit libéral comme une sorte de
remaniement ministériel qui annoncerait
de futurs changements institutionnels
mais dans quel régime politique nous
trouvons nous ces pratiques sont
honteuses parce que si vous êtes en
train de préparer en douce encore une
fois
un changement institutionnel synonyme
d'un nouveau régime politique et bien
dites le nous et vous n'ignorez pas vous
ignorez avec arrogance et
déconsidérations la colère des
Françaises et les Français et c'est
pourtant difficile de ne pas voir que
personne ne veut perdre ses deux plus
belles années de retraite pour prendre
deux années de travail les plus
difficiles le même jour de la journée
internationale de lutte pour les droits
des femmes vous apprêtez à faire passer
en force par un coup de force
institutionnel un article l'article 7
qui pénélisera en premier lieu les
femmes et vous le savez et là je voulais
m'adresser à monsieur le président
Gérard Larcher qu'il m'écoute monsieur
le président Gérard Larcher dans la nuit
d'hier vous avez été davantage le
président DLR que le président du Sénat
en se soumettant en se soumettant à
l'agenda du gouvernement avec cet
article 38 article réclamé par le
président rotaïo et applaudi par les
centristes monsieur le Président Larcher
vous décrébilisez notre institution et
travail parlementaire je m'adresse donc
à ce nouveau bloc de droit merci chers
collègues soyez raisonnable soirée pour
retirer cette réforme merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole était président
merci merci monsieur le Président
rappelle au Règlement sur la base de la
décision du 11 juin 2015 du Conseil
constitutionnel sur le caractère
effectif de l'exercice du droit
d'amendement et les exigences de clarté
de sincérité du débat parlementaire en
effet ça ça vient encore être appelé
plusieurs éléments ont été
particulièrement problématiques lors de
la dernière séance de notre assemblée ou
a régné c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
une très grande confusion la liste est
donc et mes collègues poursuivront sur
le le la liste des irubarités la
commission notamment n'a pas réellement
examiné les sous amendements de la vue
même de la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales la présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales a
déclaré ne pas avoir examiné certains
sous amendements comme la teste de
compte-rendu analytique de la séance à
sa page 69 mais a ensuite déclaré
irrecevable ces mêmes sous amendements
pour ensuite déclarer les avoir examinés
ce qui est matériellement impossible la
Commission n'a pas cité le bon fondement
pour déclarer les sous amendements
irrecevables en raison de leur
soi-disant contradiction avec
l'amendement de réécriture c'est
l'article 44 bis 3 pour seul fondement
qui a été cité alors aurait dû être
invoqué l'article 44 bis alias 9
invoquant les motifs prévus à l'article
44 bis Alina 4 la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales a omis
des informations elle n'a cité aucun
article du règlement pour déclarer les
sous amendements d'exception de
différents métiers et recevable alors
qu'elle aurait dûment énoncer qu'elle se
fondait sur lactique 44 bis aliens 10
elle a également anticipé la décision du
Sénat en déclarant irrecevable ses
abandons alors qu'elle était fondée qu'à
demander que le Sénat se prononce sur
leur seul irrévassable il recevabilité
enfin la présidence de séance n'a pas
éclairci la procédure ni garantit la
clarté la sincérité des débats la
distinction entre les deux formes
d'irrégularité leur fondement
réglementaire n'a pas non plus été
spécifié par la présidence il aurait été
il aurait été pardon souhaitable qu'il
précise les différents fondements et les
amendements concernés enfin certains
sous amendements ont finalement été
discutés en séance sans être distribué
afin que les sénateurs puissent s'en
saisir ils ont été par le Sénat pour
finalement merci cher très déclaré y
recevable impostery c'est le cas du
sous-amendement 4765
merci monsieur le Président sur le même
article et sur la même décision du 11
juin 2015 du Conseil constitutionnel sur
les exigences de clarté et de sincérité
des débats parlementaires l'organisation
de la séance la nuit dernière à nuit à
la
qui s'est déroulé dans la confusion
absolue à perturber la clarté des débats
les droits ouverts au sénateur par le
réglement intérieur n'ont pas été
respectées la séance a refusé des
rappels au règlement en parfaite
contradiction avec l'article 36 alias 3
du règlement qui dispose pourtant que la
parole est accordée sur le champ à tous
sénateurs qu'il a demandé pour un rappel
au règlement de plus les sénateurs ont
dû voter dans la précipitation et la
confusion sur une motion qu'il n'avait
pas sous les yeux la version papier de
la motion tendant opposé l'exception d'y
recevoirbilité n'a pas été distribué au
sénateur avant le vote la volonté de
passer en force n'excuse n'excuse pas
tout il faut en tenir compte je vous
remercie merci chers collègues Madame De
Marco
je poursuis le rappel au Règlement sur
la base de la décision du 11 juin 2015
du Conseil constitutionnel sur le fond
des îles sababilités sont contestables
pour plusieurs raisons une partie de
nous sous en manquements ont été
déclarés irrecevables car il
contredirait l'article 7 c'est très
contestable nos sous-amendements de
contredisaient pas l'amendement mais il
se contente dans limiter la portée nous
contestons une interprétation très
extensive du mot contredire enfin même
si cela ne relève pas proprement parler
du règlement une seconde partie de nous
sous-amendement qui visait à exempter
certains métiers du report de l'âge
légal ont été déclarés irrecevables car
il méconnerait le principe d'égalité
devant la loi mais là aussi c'est
parfaitement contestable nous
connaissons la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel qui autorise de
jurisprudence constante que le
législateur règle de façon différente
des situations différentes ou qui
dérochent au principe d'égalité pour des
raisons d'intérêt général le principe
d'égalité n'est en aucun cas un principe
absolu et vous pouvez affirme vous ne
pouvez affirmer avec certitude que ces
amendements étaient incanties
inconstitutionnel seul le Conseil
constitutionnel aurait pu le faire
nous nous demandons également pourquoi
il n'a pas été invoqué que ce motif pour
demander d'y recevoir d'habilité de nos
amendements dans les dispositifs sens
similaires monsieur le Président quand
on se livre un coup de force
réglementaire comme cela était opéré
hier il est préférable d'être d'une
incontestable rigueur
pour reprendre sereinement l'examen de
ce projet de loi le Sénat sonorerait à
annuler toutes les opérations de vote
qui ont eu lieu après la reprise de 1h45
merci cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur la souligne
monsieur le Président rappellerai
règlement aussi se référant à la
délibération du 11 juin 2015 du Conseil
constitutionnel alors
ce que l'on a vu cette nuit n'est pas
anodin et restera comme un moment
historique pour cette assemblée
pour tous ceux qui sont là depuis un
certain temps ils n'ont jamais vu ça et
il le disent il y a eu des moments de
tension des moments de combat des
moments de rappel à des règlements de
bataille de procédures ça c'est la vie
des assemblées par contre l'arbitraire
qui tombe d'un coup avec cette violence
au milieu de la nuit qui vient supprimer
des milliers d'amendements et ensuite
des milliers de sous amendements en
moins de trois quarts d'heure c'est à
dire avec l'impossibilité matérielle et
je demanderai des vérifications si
est-ce que matériellement c'est possible
et s'il faut une enquête on peut la
faire
de vérifier que les 2000 amendements
n'étaient pas recevables
alors vous avez fait tout ça mais
attention ce n'est peut-être pas un
service que vous rendez au gouvernement
parce que ce qui a frappé l'opinion et
ca mobilisé aussi beaucoup c'est que à
l'Assemblée nationale cet article
central qui est la loi c'est tout la loi
tout le reste n'existe pas s'il n'y a
pas cette mesure qui fait un impôt sur
la vie de deux ans sur la vie des
Français
il y a pas eu de discussion à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde
attendait qu'elle ait lieu là
et c'est sur cet article pas sur les
autres il y a eu près de 50 heures de
discussion ici tranquille sur tous les
autres
et c'est sur celui-là ou la France
attendait un débat que le couperait est
tombé et bien le Conseil constitutionnel
pourra apprécier la sincérité des débats
et des délibérations si aucune des deux
assemblées n'a pu discuter sérieusement
sur le fond de l'article 7 la parole est
à madame la Présidente rossignol
merci monsieur le Président mon
rappellero règlement est aussi fondé sur
un type 44 bis le Conseil
constitutionnel a deux exigences à
l'égard de nos travaux la clarté et la
sincérité je vais examiner ce qui s'est
passé hier à l'aune de ces deux
conditions en ce qui concerne la
sincérité de l'amendement déposée par
Monsieur Savary hier soir nous avons
longuement discuté en commission
monsieur Savary a longuement développé
l'article 7 le soutien qui lui apportait
jamais jamais il n'a été question d'un
amendement du rapporteur réécrivant une
partie de cet article 7 cet amendement
est sorti hier soir à 2h30 du matin
uniquement uniquement pour priver le
Sénat du débat qu'il attendait sur
l'article 7 donc je commence par dire
que c'est un sincère
c'est une manœuvre en ce qui concerne la
clarté nous avons voté le nous avons
voté le Sénat a voté des sénateurs ont
voté hier soir cette nuit dans la plus
grande confusion c'est un amendement
entre deux suspensions de séance au
moment où nous cherchions encore
qu'elles étaient les conséquences de
l'adoption éventuelle de cet amendement
par le Sénat sur les amendements que
nous avions déposés précédemment au
moment où on nous informait que nous
sous amendements que nous étions en
train de déposer était contraire à
l'amendement déposé par Monsieur Savary
contraire changer une date c'est
contraire depuis quand
depuis quand changer une date dans un
amendement est contraire c'était l'objet
de certains de nos sous amendements donc
hier soir vous avez voté un amendement
dans des conditions qui ne respectent ni
l'exigence de sincérité ni l'exigence de
clarté que le Conseil constitutionnel
nous demande merci chers collègues
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
le président mon rappelle au règlement
se fonde sur l'article 44 bis alinéa 4
il est dit dans cet article que les sous
amendements
sont recevables à condition
de n'avoir pas pour effet de contredire
l'amendement
auquel il se rapporte
or parmi les sous amendements qui ont
été déposés il en est un grand nombre
qui ne contredisent pas l'amendement
auquel il se rapporte il est
parfaitement légitime de déposer des
sous amendements qui limitent l'effet de
l'amendement qui réduisent la portée de
l'amendement qui réduisent les
conséquences de l'amendement qui
complètent ce que dit l'amendement tout
cela est légitime ce n'est pas une
contradiction donc monsieur le Président
j'ai l'honneur de vous demander
que qu'il soit procédé à un examen de
l'ensemble des sous amendements
que l'on puisse voir à mon sous
amendement par sous amendement
s'il y a contradiction car la Commission
a été en un quart d'heure dans
l'impossibilité de le faire de telle
manière que tous les sous amendements
qui ne sont pas contradictoires à
l'amendement viennent en sciences
publiques sinon c'est un véritable déni
par rapport au droit fondamental à
l'amendement et au sous-amendement qui
est le d'autres merci jacole la parole
est au président kaner
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre à mon tour sur la base de
l'article 44 bis et l'ensemble de ces
alinéas ce qui s'est passé hier soir et
particulièrement
inédit au sein du Sénat je ne reviendrai
pas sur les arguments qui ont été
développés par mes collègues il y a un
instant simplement il y a un contexte je
contexte est aggravé ce matin par la
Conférence des Présidents l'Artic 38 ne
relève pas de l'autorité de la
Conférence des Présidents le la décision
d'utiliser les amendements prioritaires
rectificatif non plus par contre
l'article 42 peut-être déclenché sur la
base d'une décision de la Conférence des
Présidents nous ne sommes opposés parce
qu'il concerne les bancs de cette
immistic mais la décision a été prise ce
qui veut dire monsieur le Président que
ce droit amendement est sous amendement
aujourd'hui pour ce qui reste de notre
débat va être encadré comme jamais au
Sénat par votre décision et par votre
capacité à vouloir plier je le dis les
arguments de notre opposition ici
représentée je le regrette c'est une
image mauvaise qui a été donnée hier
soir tous les arguments développés par
Madame Rossignol feront protéger
naturellement d'une réflexion vis-à-vis
d'un éventuel recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel je ne sais pas si je
peux vous dire de vous ressaisir en tout
cas ce que je sais oui de vous ressaisir
vous pour que le débat puisse aller
jusqu'au bout dans les meilleurs
conditions tous ces rappels au règlement
n'ont qu'un objet actif mes chers
collègues tous ces règlements dans un
seul objectif faire que le Sénat puisse
travailler dans de bonnes conditions un
texte aussi important pour nos
concitoyens c'est la volonté qui est la
nôtre je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
partagée par vous toutes merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame de La
Gontrie
merci monsieur le Président tous ceux
qui ont participé nous étions nombreux à
la séance de nuit ont pu constater
l'extrême désordre dans lequel le Sénat
a tenté de travailler et tout cela sera
examiné de près évidemment par le
Conseil constitutionnel notre collègue
Laurence Rossignol a rappelé comment le
Conseil a dans ses jurisprudences
successives instaurer désormais la
nécessité du respect de la sincérité de
la clarté du débat parlementaire nous
aurons sûrement l'occasion de revenir
sur ce principe
ultérieurement lors de nos débats je le
sens mais je voudrais revenir sur la
façon dont les sous-amendements ont été
traités plusieurs collègues ont fait
mais je voudrais compléter ces ces
commentaires lorsque madame la
Présidente de roche a donc fait
connaître lire ce habilité décrétée on
peut dire les choses comme ça sur des
sous amendements qu'il n'avaient jamais
été même lus par la commission il s'est
passé un phénomène encore plus
caricatural à 3 heures du matin le
groupe
communiste a déposé de nouveaux sous
amendements en nombre et la présidente
de la commission dit les choses
suivantes telles que repris dans le
compte rendu analytique je cite d'autres
sous amendements viennent d'être déposés
dans la même veine ils sont pareillement
contradiction avec l'amendement du
rapporteur les mêmes causes produisant
les mêmes effets la Commission les
déclare donc irrecevables donc nous
avons vu une présidente de commission à
son banc avec des commisses avec des
amendements qu'elle n'avait même pas vu
ni lu décrété que par principe ils
étaient irrecevables en contradiction
totale avec le règlement et la
recevabilité des 10 sous amendements
nous demandons donc que l'ensemble de
ces sous amendements soit premièrement
examiner formellement par la commission
deuxièmement que leur irrecevabilité
soit explicite et que infini il soit
réellement examiné par le Sénat
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
nous prenons acte de tous ces rappels au
règlement
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois françois-Noël Buffet
malgré tout il faudrait redire ce qui
s'est passé hier soir hier soir le
rapporteur a déposé un amendement
réécrivant totalement les dispositions
une partie de l'article 7 c'est sur la
base de cette réécriture que nos
collègues de l'opposition ont déposé
3000 amendements ils ont admis sous
amendement pardon qui se sont leurs
anciens amendements qui se sont traduits
en sous-amendement en réalité ils ont
donc changé de nature
et c'est ce changement de nature qui
fait que l'application habituelle la
règle fait que dès lors qu'ils sont
contraires à l'article la rédaction qui
avait été faite par la maman de Monsieur
Savary était établi il ne peut ils ont
été déclarés irrecevables c'est le
principe qui est admis par tout le monde
depuis longtemps et c'est la règle
normale et habituelle je voudrais redire
si j'ai encore quelques minutes c'est
que nos collègues de l'opposition ont
clairement indiqué il a été constaté je
le crois par la commission la présente
me semble-t-il la dire ne pas dire de
bêtises que la rédaction était
absolument de ces sous amendements était
absolument identique à celle des
amendements qui avaient été déposés et
que par conséquent l'analyse pouvait
être plus rapide deuxième point deuxième
point et j'en aurai terminé puisque le
président Kader fait référence à la
Conférence des Présidents de ce matin je
voudrais dire clairement ce qui a été
dit puisque j'y participais il a été dit
que la volonté du groupe d'opposition
était de ne pas voter le texte et
d'utiliser tous les moyens en
sa possession pour pouvoir s'opposer au
vote du texte mais mais
il a été dit également par les
représentants de l'opposition que la
majorité pouvait aussi utiliser les
moyens qui étaient à sa disposition au
sein du règlement pour voter le texte
donc voilà la réalité du débat
d'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
la parole et Madame linman et puis
ensuite il y aura une réponse de Madame
de roche et puis ensuite on passera à
l'examen des amendements
merci monsieur le Président rappelle au
règlement que nous n'allions pas au bout
de l'examen du texte ça pourrait presque
favoriser certains membres de la
majorité sanatoriale qui sont bien
embarrassées par cette situation
deuxième point que je voulais aborder
c'est cette formule qu'a eu la
présidente de roche hier c'est à la page
69 du compte-rendu à la Haïti
elle dit la même motion s'appliquerait
au nouveau sous amendement reçu trois
petits points Pierre Laurent dit alors
on est à la lumière elle est restée
allumée Madame Catherine de roche
reprend y compris ceux que la Commission
n'a pas eu le temps d'examiner en effet
ils sont donc ils sont dans la même
veine que les précédents alors qu'on
oppose les recevabilité à des
amendements qu'on a lu pourquoi pas mais
qu'on insère de l'état d'esprit de nos
groupes le contenu d'amendement me
paraît extrêmement grave
[Applaudissements]
nous explique qu'une partie des
amendements devenue sous amendements
changer de nature parce que il y avait
nécessité de cohérence si je puis dire
avec le contenu de l'amendement
n'est vrai que pour une partie du
raisonnement développé par Madame de
roche car l'autre il y a un paquet
qu'elle a motivé avec ses motifs on le
conteste mais celui-là à la limite on
peut en discuter en revanche l'autre
partie elle est ils ont été
retoqués j'allais dire juger et
recevable au motif de l'égalité du
non-respect de l'égalité républicaine
mais ça ça motive de contenu
constitutionnel qui ne change pas de
nature quand on a un amendement ou un
sous amendement
soit l'amendement respecte l'égalité
républicaine potentiellement et quand il
devient sous amendement il change pas de
nature au regard de ce critère
RSI proprement donc
merci chers collègues donc madame la
Présidente de roche
merci monsieur le président
donc
on va revenir si vous me laissez parler
ce serait mieux c'est pas votre habitude
ça j'ai remarqué mais en fin de temps en
temps forcez-vous un peu voilà
en présentant la motion qui tendait à
opposer l'exception des recevabilité je
voudrais revenir brièvement en effet sur
les questions qui ont été soulevées au
cours du débat d'hier sur la régularité
la procédure tout d'abord comment
l'exception d'y recevabilité bien prévu
par notre règlement et jusqu'à sa
récente très forme les commissions
avaient notamment recours pour proposer
au Sénat de déclarer et recevable des
amendements qui créent une habilitation
du gouvernement à légiférer par
ordonnance ou allergir le champ d'une
ordonnance d'une façon générale
l'exception d'y recevabilité permet au
Sénat de ne pas examiner des amendements
ou des sous amendements contraire à la
Constitution
je l'ai dit clairement hier et là c'est
le pourquoi les amendements que
l'amendement de la commission a fait
tomber hier soir était des amendements
d'obstruction catalogue des professions
suppression d'alinéa en rafale après
l'examen des 70
dans ce calme on se calme on a encore la
soirée donc ne commencez pas vous
énerver ils sont d'ailleurs assez
classiques et on peut les retrouver dans
les différentes réformes de retraite
leur seul objet dilatoire les
amendements portant sur le fond du texte
ont été préservés c'était l'objet de
l'amendement du rapporteur Savary
c'était de faire tomber en effet tous
ces amendements dilatoires et de pouvoir
se consacrer et de pouvoir se consacrer
au fond du texte et un vrai débat qui
intéresse nos concitoyens
les sous amendements déposés en masque
quelques minutes après le dépôt de
l'amendement du rapporteur était les
mêmes si parce que je suis passé du
temps ce qui est en commission bien vu
que je n'étais pas au début de la
commission j'étais dans la salle où en
examinait tous les amendements
d'ailleurs au départ vous avez présenté
non pas des sous-amendements mais c'est
intitulés amendement vous savez très
bien que non non madame on peut les
ressortir on peut les ressortir
des amendements de vous finissez et il y
a eu des sous-amendements qui ont été
déposés en effet certains groupes ne se
sont au demeurant même pas la peine de
les modifier c'est ce que je vous dis
par leur nombre et leur objet ils
poursuivait le même objectif que les
amendements empêchaient le déroulement
de la discussion et gagner du temps
ces amendements d'obstructions ont été
déposés conformément au règlement mais
l'exception d'y recevabilité l'est aussi
nous assumons nous aussi de répondre à
l'obstruction permise par le règlement
par les moyens permis par le règlement
la clarté des débats il y a une
certainement lorsque nous sortons c'est
long tunnel de discussion qui n'ont
d'autre objet que de refaire à l'envie
la discussion générale et nous ce que
nous souhaitons c'est passer à l'examen
des articles sur le fond le camp
certains orateurs
oh monsieur monsieur
vraiment monsieur Assouline si vous
pouvez aujourd'hui je voulais dire
arrêtez de hurler en permanence
si mais si vous rendez même pas compte
[Applaudissements]
on dit toujours que lorsqu'on hurle
c'est qu'on a pas beaucoup d'arguments
certains orateurs se sont étonnés que
l'exception d'y recevabilité arrive
après l'examen en commission et soit
opposé à des sous-amendements
identiques à des amendements examinés
par la connaît la commission
reconnaissant ainsi qu'il s'agit c'est
bien de même vous l'avez dit et qu'il ne
fait donc pas des heures à la Commission
pour les examiner je voudrais tout
d'abord rappeler qu'un amendement
recevable ne fait pas forcément ça a été
dit un sous amendement recevable un
amendement édifie le texte un sous
amendement manifestement dont il ne doit
pas contredire le sens et c'est ce que
vous contestez mais on pourrait je
voudrais ensuite indiquer que
l'exception d'y recevabilité s'oppose en
séance et que ce n'est pas parce qu'un
amendement est examiné en commission
qu'elle ne peut pas par la suite lui
être opposé en séance c'est ce que nous
avons fait et je peux vous dire que pour
être allé dans la salle où les
amendements étaient examinés il y avait
un nombre très important et aucun
amendement n'est passé dans les mailles
du filet merci Madame ma présidente
monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
effectivement je partage je partage une
partie de vos propos il y a eu 48 heures
48 heures de discussions depuis quelques
jours avant d'arriver à cet article 7
il y a eu
deux deux articles déterminants pour
cette réforme des retraites à savoir
l'article 1 qui ferme les régimeux
spéciaux
nous étions favorables de ce côté là
vous étiez défavorable le premier parti
et puis après vous avez proposé des
dates de fermeture un peu plus tardives
mais vous avez proposé la fermeture des
services des régimes spéciaux comme quoi
parfois on peut se retrouver et puis il
y a eu sur l'article 2
la discussion importante le débat sur
l'emploi des seniors avec des
propositions venant du gouvernement pour
certaines l'index des seniors venant de
ces bancs là pour d'autres le CDI senior
et vous vous êtes opposés vous vous êtes
opposé à cela et c'est votre droit ces
débats ont duré 4 heures sur 48 heures
sur 48 heures de discussion 4 heures de
débat car effectivement le reste était
un monologue où vous présentiez votre
vision très apocalyptique du monde du
travail avec votre volonté de vous
opposer sans présenter vos amendements
car si nous avions entendu la
présentation de ces amendements je pense
que ceux qui nous écoutent auraient
changé d'avis
et puis ensuite vous dire
vous dire que effectivement vous avez eu
un effet de surprise mais la vivacité de
lecture de madame la Présidente pour
juger de la recevabilité
de leur sevabiliter de ses amendements
est identique à votre vivacité pour
proposer dans la minute 3000 sous
amendements
quel effet de surprise
pas quelque part une préparation
on pourrait penser contenu de ce qui se
passe qu'au départ que nous ayons des
discussions que l'on vous soupçonne de
vouloir vous entraver au bon déroulé des
débats mais quand on ressort 3000
amendements c'est qu'on veut s'opposer
au débat et en conséquence dites-le
clairement dites-le nous ne voulons pas
voter cette réforme nous ne voulons pas
débattre sur un sujet sociétal et arrivé
au vote mais dites-le n'hésitez pas
on avait clos les rappelles au règlement
il y a eu des réponses qui ont été
apportées nous allons maintenant passer
dans la discussion des articles
écoutez je pense qu'on a laissé 99
monsieur le Président vous êtes
intervenus déjà sur l'acte sur le rappel
au règlement il y a pas une deuxième
intervention mais je n'ai pas j'entends
la demande de suspension mais c'est à
mon appréciation j'ai la prestation du
président de séance de savoir s'il faut
suspendre ou pas la séance mais donc
je vais la suspendre 5 minutes monsieur
le Président la séance 5 minutes
monsieur le Président je vous demande
voilà
et nous votant fort dans ces débats au
Sénat sur la réforme des retraites avec
une nouvelle suspension de séance après
les débats très tendus de la nuit
dernière les sénateurs de gauche qui ont
multiplié les rappels au règlement pour
dénoncer les outils réglementaires qui
ont été utilisés par la droite
sénatoriale la nuit dernière et aussi le
fait que la commission des affaires
sociales a déclaré et recevable des
milliers d'amendements de la gauche
après un examen très rapide de ces
amendements des sous-amendements
précisément pour en parler on va
retrouver Quentin calmé qui a suivi la
reprise de ces débats cet après-midi
Quentin on peut le dire que à la gauche
est reparti sur les chapeaux de roue oui
exactement Alex et on repart exactement
là où on s'est interrompu hier à 3h30 si
vous étiez avec nous en direct sur
l'antenne de public Sénart peut-être pas
alors on va réexpliquer ce qui s'est
joué hier la droite a tenté de couper
court à la discussion autour de 1100
amendements déposés par la gauche et qui
venait ralentir le débat autour de
l'article 7
l'ancien tel prix et bien René Paul
Savary leur apporteur de la branche
vieillesse qui vient de s'exprimer à
déposer un amendement à l'article 7 un
amendement qui venait redéfinir
l'article 7 avec des termes assez
proches de ce qu'il y avait à l'origine
dans le texte sauf que cette manœuvre de
la part de la Commission de la droite et
du centre a eu pour effet de faire
tomber 1100 amendements qui étaient donc
en cours de discussion café la gauche à
ce moment-là hier elle a tenté de
déposer des centaines de sous
amendements et ce sont ces sous
amendements là qui ont été jugés
irrecevables en une demi-heure de en une
demi-heure de réunion de la commission
d'affaires sociales cette décision là
est critiquée depuis maintenant la
reprise de 16h30 par des dizaines de
rappels réglement de la gauche et on a
entendu les justifications de la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales également du rapporteur qui ont
essayé d'expliquer pourquoi il y avait
eu ce rejet massif de susamment et la
gauche qui de son côté qu'il y a un
détournement du Règlement du Sénat et on
entend du toutes ces prises de parole
aussi de la gauche qui dit que cela va
fragiliser le texte
constitutionnellement car il y a
maintenant des doutes sur la sincérité
des débats et qui donc rejette le fait
que leur amendements n'étaient pas et
bien admissible au débat Alex merci
beaucoup Quentin et pendant cette
suspension de séance pour en parler
j'accueille sur ce plateau Olivier Paco
bonjour vous êtes sénateur rattaché au
groupe les républicains ici au Sénat un
mot sur ces multiples rappels au
règlement de la gauche qui dénonce les
pratiques de la droite sénatoriale sur
la procédure de débat sur cette réforme
des retraites les centres de gauche
estime que leurs collègues de droite
porte un coup très fort au droit
d'amendement qui a un droit d'amendement
constitutionnel des parlementaires
comment vous réagissez écoutez si
la constitutionnalité des débats a été
entre guillemets mise à mal
je crois que nos collègues socialistes
saisiront éventuellement qui de droit a
priori ce n'est pas le cas en fait ils
sont dans la lignée de leur attitude
depuis le début de l'ouverture des
débats c'est-à-dire qu'il multiplie les
prises de parole c'est une forme un peu
plus polie d'obstruction n'est plus ni
moins aujourd'hui ce que nous attendons
ce que nous espérons c'est de pouvoir
continuer à débattre du fameux article 7
et notamment il reste beaucoup
d'amendements quand même il y en a un
millier qui ont effectivement qui sont
tombés entre guillemets il en reste
beaucoup sur des sujets très variés
comme 75 il en reste 75 c'est pas neutre
moi j'en défendrai un personnellement
pour rétablir l'égalité de traitement
entre les professeurs des écoles et les
enseignants du secondaire pour l'âge de
départ à la retraite tout ça il faut
l'aborder et si on continue
effectivement dans l'obstruction ce qui
est le cas là depuis un peu plus d'une
demi-heure voire trois quarts d'heure on
avancera pas et donc en face la droite
sénatoriale on va continuer à utiliser
ces outils réglementaires pour accélérer
accélérer les débats
écoutez on est là pour travailler on est
là pour voter un texte donc ce sont des
outils réglementaires qui appartiennent
effectivement au règlement intérieur
mais il s'agit pas de la part pas des
républicains puisque c'est quand même
une décision qui avait été prise par le
président de séance de biaiser le débat
mais de au contraire le fluidifier merci
beaucoup Olivet Paco je vous laisse
regagner à l'hémicycle du Sénat puisque
la séance a repris sur cette réforme des
retraites et puis se balayer l'ensemble
des sous-amendements qui ont été
déclarés irrecevables
je pense que si j'avais pu vous demander
cela vous me l'auriez refusé donc merci
pour la suspension préalable merci donc
la suspension n'a pas permis la
commission de regarder mais enfin ça a
été regardé par la présidente elle l'a
dit tout à l'heure donc on va on va
commencer comme le souhaitait la plupart
d'entre vous discuter sur le fond sur
l'article 7 et donc on a un certain
nombre d'amendements en discussion
commune dont un certain nombre ont été
retirés dont un certain nombre ont été
retiré donc l'amendement 165 230 ont été
retirés nous avons le 1142 de Monsieur
Ménonville
est-ce qu'il est là Monsieur Menonville
non il a retiré le 2496 madame Boyer a
été retiré donc nous passons au 263
madame Lubin qui le défend
qui ne défend cet amendement
même les bain
merci monsieur le Président moi j'ai
proposé un amendement avec mon groupe
qui tend au lieu de donner une surcote
de 5% aux femmes qui arrivent avec tout
leur trimestres à l'âge de 63 ans donc
leur permettre d'avoir 5 % de plus quand
elles prennent leur retraite à 64 ans ce
qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas tout à
fait juste à nos yeux dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui une femme qui arrive à 62
ans avec tous ces trimestres et qui
décident de volontairement de travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans peut avoir 10% de
surcotte donc là avec cette proposition
au final elle perd 5% de surcote donc
nous ce que nous proposons ça serait
bien si elle pouvait avoir un peu de
silence à côté s'il vous plaît merci et
donc non mais c'est difficile c'est
[Musique]
c'est mon oreille gauche qui est
sensible pardon et donc et donc moi ce
que je ce que je propose c'est que pour
les femmes qui ont des trimestres qui
ont eu des enfants et qui peuvent
valider des trimestres supplémentaires
qui à 62 ans ont tout leur trimestres
qu'elles prennent leur retraite à 62 ans
puisque de toute façon elles ont la
durée totale grâce au trimestre qu'elles
auront acquis pour enfants voilà c'est
un amendement qui me paraît comment dire
maman demande de justice et de logique
quelque part voilà
le 1961 monsieur Chassin
il est retiré donc on a pu en fait qu'un
un seul amendement puisque le 2189 a été
retiré le 168 aussi le 1972 aussi le
2190 aussi donc sur cet amendement 2633
la commission la ville de la Commission
oui merci effectivement c'est
intéressant de penser à cette carrière
des maires de famille qui se traduis
derrière par des pensions qui sont pas
toujours à la hauteur et les majorations
de tirer les majorations d'assurances
qui sont accordées pour les maires de
famille sont effectivement tout à fait
intéressantes à la fois pour combler la
carrière et aider à arriver au taux
plein mais également pour avoir une
reconnaissance par rapport à cette
volonté de concilier une carrière et une
maternité elles sont cependant
différentes entre le régime public et
privé puisque c'est quatre trimestres
pour la maternité plus 4 trimestres à
distribuer pour l'éducation des enfants
d'un côté et seulement deux trimestres
dans le régime public donc c'est
apprendre en compte la différence madame
Lubin entre un âge avancé de départ d'un
an et une surcote c'est-à-dire qu'on
continue à travailler comparé à 64 ans
et à ce moment là ce que nous proposons
c'est de prendre en compte cette effort
supplémentaire et de le récompenser
l'avantage c'est que on va dans la
philosophie de la réforme que
voulez-vous c'est quand même les
Français l'ont bien compris travailler
plus et un deuxième avantage par hassas
c'est que ça augmente la pension de ces
femmes ça réduit l'écart entre les
niveaux de pension entre les hommes et
les femmes c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons choisi ce dispositif et qui
argument supplémentaire me semble-t-il
permet de pas être discriminatoire par
rapport à la Cour européenne si vous
faites un âge avancé pour les femmes
réservées aux femmes il y a une
différence de traitement par rapport aux
hommes c'est la raison pour laquelle
notre amendement je vous invite à le
soutenir et vraiment la meilleure
solution par rapport à ces difficultés
que peuvent rencontrer les maires de
famille donc c'est un favorable sur
le ministre
merci monsieur le Président de madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame et
monsieur le rapporteur la vie du
Gouvernement est défavorable pour
plusieurs raisons la première concerne
cette question d'égalité que monsieur le
rapporteur vient d'évoquer je n'y
reviens pas il y a une deuxième raison
qui est relève de la mécanique même de
l'amendement que Madame Libin a défendu
la surcotte quand on parle de surcote
est accessible aujourd'hui et elle sera
demain dans les mêmes conditions à deux
conditions cumulatives la première est
d'atteindre d'avoir atteint l'âge
d'ouverture des droits tels que fixés au
régime général et la deuxième est
d'avoir atteint la durée d'affiliation
au régime requise pour pouvoir faire
valoir ses droits à taux plein et c'est
vraiment ces deux conditions qu'il y a
une possibilité de surcote et donc une
surcote qui intervient après la od et à
condition d'avoir l'intégralité des
trimestres requis pour demander aux
bénéficier d'une retraite à taux plein
il y a une difficulté dans l'amendement
que vous présentez madame la sénatrice
qui consiste à imaginer créer des âges
différenciés finalement non pas entre
les femmes et les hommes mais tel que
vous le présentez entre les mères et les
hommes puisqu'il faudrait bénéficier de
trimestre au titre de la maternité je le
dis de manière un peu rapide pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'un âge avancé notre
préférence va un amendement adopter par
la commission des affaires sociales dont
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de parler qui a
été initié par le président Retailleau
parce qu'il permet de cumuler les
avantages de deux systèmes premier
avantage et qu'il permet pour des femmes
qui ont une carrière hachée nous savons
que les femmes sont plus exposées que
les hommes en cariaché de pouvoir
continuer à mettre en oeuvre et utiliser
les trimestres validé au titre de la
maternité pour compléter leur durée
d'affiliation requise et ainsi pouvoir
partir à l'âge d'ouverture des droits en
offrant les conditions de fixation de
celui-ci à ton plan et son décote c'est
un élément de protection parce que ça
permet justement d'éviter la décote pour
des femmes en cariacées si tentaient que
le nombre de trimestres ainsi validé
suffisant la deuxième utilisation qui
permet cet amendement adopté par la
commission des affaires sociales et de
dire que si un assuré
plus généralement une assurée mais c'est
générique a atteint à la fois l'âge de
63 ans et dans le même temps la durée
d'affiliation requise 168 trimestre
aujourd'hui 172 demain en 2027 il y a
non pas la possibilité mais
automatiquement une surcote pour les
trimestres cotisés entre les 63 ans si
tenté que la Dar était atteinte et les
64 ans ce qui a l'échelle d'une année
représente une majoration non pas des
trimestres mais de la totalité de la
pension de 5% hauteur de 1,25% de
batterie et donc la préférence du
gouvernement et ça justifiera la vie
favorable ultérieurement à l'amendement
adoptée par la commission tient au fait
que par cet amendement nous gardons le
bénéfice d'une majoration de durée pour
les assurer principalement les femmes
ayant une carrière hachée ou incomplète
à la fin et que nous pouvons prévoir une
possibilité de surcote pour celle qui a
une carrière complète et ça répond à une
évolution de société évolution de
société qui fait que le taux d'emploi
des femmes a progressé c'est heureux et
qui fait que la conciliation de la vie
professionnelle avec la maternité et
sinon plus facile en tout cas moins
difficile qu'elle ne l'était il y a 20
30 ou 40 ans et donc c'est cet intérêt
là qu'on trouvons à l'amendement alors
que celui que vous proposait propose des
âges différenciés qui ne nous paraissent
pas très acceptable endroit en tout cas
au regard du principe d'ingalité et
peut-être me connaître ce double aspect
bon pour toutes ces raisons la vie est
favorable et c'est la justifiera
monsieur le Président un avis
défavorable sur les autres amendements à
l'exception de celui de la commission
des affaires sociales ils ont été
retirés les autres amendements monsieur
le ministre donc j'ai des demandes
d'explication de vote madame meunier
les amendements se retirent avant d'être
discuté où est l'esprit du débat du
Sénat où est la démocratie
si chers
merci monsieur le Président alors
puisque on parle du principe d'égalité
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est l'égalité
quand à 43 ans on a les conditions d'un
taux plein l'égalité entre les mers et
les femmes voilà et même voilà donc là
on Déroche à l'égalité cette dérogation
que vous comptez tout à l'heure
une autre égalité ça serait de dire 5%
pour tous ceux qui ont atteint homme ou
femme et dans les femmes mères ou femmes
sans enfant le taux plein à 63 ans mais
je voudrais surtout insister ce que vous
dites monsieur leur rapporteur à savoir
que grâce au fait que vous les obligez à
travailler un an plus elles vont avoir
une meilleure pension mais c'est
méconnettes le mécanisme de la surcotte
quand on dit UNE surcotte de 5%
c'est actuarielle vous devez le savoir
ça veut dire que le patrimoine retraite
c'est-à-dire tout ce qu'elles auront en
termes de retraite de pension de
retraite est strictement égal et neutre
par rapport à l'augmentation de 5%
donnée par la surcote c'est un principe
actuarial neutre ça veut dire que vous
oubliez un petit détail vous dites elles
ont une pension supérieure vous oubliez
qu'elle travaille un an plus et pendant
qu'elle travaille un an plus elle ne
touche pas de pension et le patrimoine
retraite on y reviendra qui est la somme
des pensions dans toute la durée de
retraite est strictement égal dans un
cas comme dans un autre donc vous et les
femmes je serai tenté de dire si à 63
ans avant elle travaillait elle avait
une surcote elle gagne moins avec cette
réforme forcément puisque
puisque comme l'a dit ma collègue
pouvait la voir des 62 ans donc voilà ne
dites pas que vous augmentez les
pensions parce que certes vous les
augmentez c'est un travail jusqu'à 70
ans aussi elle augmentera sa pension
mais elle perdra en patrimoine retraite
merci chers collègues la parole est au
président Retailleau
rappelle le règlement je demande
l'application d'article 38
merci monsieur le président
donc on a été saisi par Monsieur le
Président du Groupe républicain d'une
demande de clôture des explications de
vote sur l'amendement 2633
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues je
vous rappelle qu'on aplication de
l'article 38 alinéa du règlement
la clôture peut être proposée lorsque au
moins 2 orateurs d'avis contraire sont
intervenus
conformément à la ligne à 3 du même
article
je vais consulter le Sénat alors
attendez d'abord d'abord il faut qu'il y
ait deux interventions pardon
il peut y avoir
sur la clôture il peut y avoir une
explication de votre part groupe donc
madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président retaille vous avez
fait tomber quasiment tous nos
amendements sur l'article 7 vous voulez
vous voulez un débat le plus restreint
possible même vos collègues qui avaient
des amendements c'est la secte Jones des
amendements il se suicide tous
et quand on a un amendement qui porte
sur la question de des bonifications
pour les agents de la fonction publique
ou des majorations de durées d'assurance
pour les femmes du secteur privé même
pas celui-là vous voulez qu'on discute
même pas celui-là un 8 mars mais vous
vous rendez compte que vous faites mais
c'est plus c'est plus c'est une honte
c'est plus ce que vous nous quand tu
permets c'est plus l'application du
règlement c'est plus l'application du
règlement c'est une volonté délibérée de
faire taire l'opposition par tous les
moyens y compris sur les sujets parce
que la personne va le dire nous
expliquer qu'on est hors sujet que ces
contradictoires qu'on peut pas en parler
et tout à l'heure sur les amendements de
Monsieur Savary on aura le droit de
s'exprimer ou faire comment on fait on
fait un mot aux présidents mais j'ai le
président pourriez-vous s'il vous plaît
nous dire si on aura le droit de
s'exprimer je vous remercie beaucoup de
votre attention c'est ça l'idée c'est de
nous humilier en plus mais c'est pas
nous vous humilier c'est les femmes
toutes les femmes
merci
merci chers collègues monsieur Lemoine
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président sur
l'application cet article 38 on entend
beaucoup de récrimination mais
j'aimerais que nous nous souvenions des
conditions dans lesquelles nous nous
sommes fixés tous ensemble cette règle
quelque part de bien vivre ensemble
voilà et bien oui et bien oui
tout cela est issu
d'un rapport qui a été fait par un
membre de la majorité à l'époque
UMP un membre de l'opposition PS c'était
en mars 2015 le bureau du Sénat a adopté
ce rapport dans ce rapport figurait
cette recommandation cette
recommandation était inscrite dans la
proposition de résolution que le
président de l'archet a déposé c'était
l'article 10 de cette proposition de
résolution et vous pouvez aller voir les
travaux tant commission qu'en séance cet
article 10 qui désormais inscrit
l'article 38 dans notre règlement notre
Constitution commune et bien il n'y a eu
aucun amendement le remettant en cause
ni en commission ni en séance il était
adopté sans modification il n'y a donc
pas eu à l'époque de révolution contre
cet article il y a même eu un
assentiment large et
je dois dire d'ailleurs que ce chantier
sur le règlement il faisait suite à des
premiers réflexions enclenchées par
Jean-Pierre Bel à l'époque et donc tout
cela je crois que nous l'avons assez
largement décidé tous ensemble j'ai
entendu hier dans les débats l'un des
orateurs
sur les bancs de la gauche dire nul ne
peut se prévaloir de sa propre turpitude
je crois que ça s'applique parfaitement
la situation que nous vivons aujourd'hui
merci chers collègues madame Cohen pour
le groupe RCE
monsieur le Président Retailleau vous
sortez l'article 38 pour nous empêcher
de parler alors on va dire du côté des
bancs LR bah oui mais finalement on est
déjà mercredi donc nous avons
suffisamment des battu ça n'est pas la
conception que nous avons du débat en
plus on a dit que l'article 7 c'était
vraiment le cœur de la réforme et en
plus vous attaquez un amendement le 8
mars qui concerne mais oui mes chers
collègues ça ne vous plaît pas mais
c'est la journée de lutte pour les
droits des femmes vous attaquez un
amendement qui peut effectivement
permettre un débat sur quelle est notre
conception de l'égalité professionnelle
quel est notre conception de l'égalité
au niveau des retraites quelle est notre
conception de la progression des
salaires et des carrières féminines vous
n'en voulez pas et en plus moi j'entends
une petite pratique quand même que j'ai
dénoncé au nom de mon groupe quand il a
quand nous avons présenté la motion
référendaire j'entends une petite
musique au niveau des bancs LR soutenu
par les bancs du gouvernement qu'est-ce
que vous voulez favoriser vous voulez
pas favoriser les femmes vous voulez
favoriser les maires de famille c'est un
choix qui est vraiment problématique
nous nous voulons l'égalité absolue pour
toutes les femmes et en plus vous n'avez
pas dû lire non plus cet amendement là
de ma collègue parce que ils portent sur
les droits familiaux ça devrait vous
intéresser monsieur Retailleau vous qui
prenez la famille comme étant le net
plus ultra papa Maman Les enfants il
faut un petit peu réfléchir
merci chers collègues
alors
madame pour ces Mons pour le groupe
c'est
[Musique]
si vous voulez
monsieur le Président moi j'invite les
Français à réécouter les trois
interventions qui vous qui ont précédé
et qui ont vous ont fait dire qu'il faut
que le débat s'arrête ces trois
interventions regardez messieurs les
Français le font on était au fond quand
je parlais quand même de patrimoine
retraite et de calcul actuariale j'étais
au fond bon donc j'en déduis que vous ne
voulez pas effectivement qu'on débattre
de l'article 7 et je vous rappelle quand
même que vous avez osé à l'Assemblée
nationale vous vous réclamez des
syndicats pour dire que c'était quand
même très triste de ne pas avoir débattu
de l'article 7 nous y sommes nous avons
jusqu'à dimanche il y avait peut-être
deux jours sur l'article 7 et vous le et
vous ne voulez pas les avoir ce que vous
voulez c'est qu'on ne discute pas de
l'article 7 parce que c'est dans
l'article 7 qui a les conséquences sur
les travailleurs inég
mes chers collègues et il y a encore sur
cet article 7 pas mal d'amendements donc
qui nous permettront quand même
d'aborder je l'espère en tout cas le
fond du sujet et
pour l'instant nous sommes dans
l'application du règlement dans
l'application de l'article 38 du
recrutement qui a été demandé par le
groupe les républicains et qui prévoit
strictement les modalités du débat sur
la proposition de clôture à savoir un
orateur par groupe
donc c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire est-ce qu'il y a encore des
groupes qui demandent à s'exprimer
monsieur Canevet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues j'ai
l'impression à entendre les propos que
je viens d'entendre justement que
certains confondent le débat et
l'obstruction à quoi a-t-on assisté
depuis à quoi a-t-on assisté depuis
plusieurs jours ce sont des tentatives
d'obstruction ce n'est pas le débat et
le débat devrait avoir lieu si justement
vous étiez respectueux de la capacité de
chacun à pouvoir s'exprimer et le groupe
de l'Union centriste regrette le groupe
de l'Union centrée je regrette justement
que par l'obstruction par la
prolongation des débats par des
amendements qui n'ont aucun sens parce
qu'ils sont similaires il suffit de les
présenter de façon rationnelle et le
débat pour avoir lieu donc on n'a pas
d'autre choix à mon avis que de soutenir
la proposition qui vient d'être faite
pour pouvoir avancer et pouvoir enfin
examiner les vrais sujets à l'ordre du
jour de ce texte
merci chers collègues
donc je vais soumettre aux voix
l'application de cet article 38
conformément à son alinéa 3 cet article
je vais consulter le Sénat à main lever
qui est pour l'application de l'article
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
l'article 38 donc s'applique et par
conséquent nous
passons alors le vote sur l'amendement
donc avec deux avis défavorables de la
Commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté alors
ensuite nous avons une motion
4766 qui tend à opposé d'exceptions
[Musique]
oui merci avec motion des recevabilité
sur deux
amendements les
2378 et les 432 ce sont
pour les mêmes motifs qu'hier que ces
amendements qui concernent des
catégories particulières d'assurer son
contraire aux principes d'égalité
consacrés par l'article 6 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen
c'est le rapporteur alors il y en
aurateur contre la motion des
recevabilité
on est dans la motion des recevabilité
monsieur Assouline
vous l'avez pas
la motion est à l'encontre de deux
amendements de 1378 432
monsieur Assouline
oui bien entendu que c'est de la même
veine et
on a donné les explications de cette
nuit on les a continué dans ces débats
au Sénat sur la réforme des retraites
alors pour vous préciser un petit peu
les choses on le rappelle en dessinateur
sont sur l'article 7 qui reporte l'âge
légal de départ à 64 ans et il discutait
d'un amendement socialiste pour
permettre aux maires de famille de
conserver leur trimestre gagné grâce à
la parentalité même si elle n'avait pas
atteint l'âge légal à 64 ans et à ce
moment-là et bien la droite sénatoriale
a dégainé le fameux article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat alors pour en parler
je vais retrouver quand un calmer en
tribune de l'hémicycle Quentin
rappelez-nous un peu ce que c'est cet
article 38 oui elle vous le disiez Alex
en est en train de discuter sur un
amendement socialiste un de Monique
cubain il y a eu trois prises de parole
c'est le maximum que l'on a atteint pour
l'instant sur le fond des articles et là
Bruno retaillew a demandé effectivement
l'application de l'article 38 qui vient
contraindre le nombre d'orateurs par
amendement puis provoquer un vote ça
permet bien d'empêcher les socialistes
en l'occurrence la gauche sénatale plus
généralement de multiplier les
explications de vote les prises de
parole sur un amendement et ça vient
d'être dénoncé encore une fois comme une
forme bien de bâillon de l'opposition
sénatoriale par la gauche sénatoriale
Alex merci Quentin et les sénateurs sont
en train de discuter d'une motion d'y
recevabilité à la Commission des
inverses sociales qui déclarent de
nouveaux amendements déposés par la
gauche y recevable on écoute David à
souligne les choses sont claires les
choses sont claires vous avez moi je
vais moi pour moi rien n'est secondaire
mais quand on vient argumenter quand on
vient quand on vient argumenter ici que
il y a des milliers d'amendements un peu
trop
similaire pour les retirer là c'est le
seul qui est maintenu et vous mettez
l'article 38 vous empêcher le débat et
vous ne voulez pas discuter de l'article
7 qui n'a pas été débattu à l'Assemblée
nationale merci c'est un scandale merci
cher collègue
quelle est la vie du gouvernement sur
cette motion monsieur le ministre
merci à Monsieur le Président
gouvernement de conteste jamais sur ce
texte comme sur les autres les décisions
de la commission des commissions tant
pour la recevabilité que pour les
recevabilités donc je m'en remets
évidemment au Sénat monsieur Assouline
dit à l'instant qu'un certain nombre
d'amendements pouvaient avoir un
caractère secondaire j'en prends acte et
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à plusieurs
reprises dans les séances précédentes
qu'il est vrai que parmi les nombreux
amendements qui avaient été déposés
ensuite transporté en sous-amendement et
là aussi sans juger de la recevabilité
ou de dire recevabilité certains nous
surprenaient à la fois par leur carrière
leur caractère redondants ou encore par
exemple ce qu'il prévoyait de maintenir
à 62 plutôt que 64 ans l'âge de départ à
la retraite des internes en médecine si
vous connaissez beaucoup d'interdes en
médecine de 62 ou 64 ans cela peut
interroger cela monte juste le caractère
répétitif de l'opération et donc
évidemment je me remets à la vie de la
Commission
merci
Monsieur le Ministre donc j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains sur cette motion
d'irres-savvabilité
il va être procédé au scooter public
dans les conditions fixées par article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
et les sénateurs qui sont donc en train
de voter sur l'irrecevabilité ou non de
deux amendements qui ont été déposés par
la gauche et que la commission des
affaires sociales considère comme y
recevable notamment au nom de notre
Constitution et de l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes ce sont les
arguments qui ont été avancés par la
commission des affaires sociales et donc
ce que dit la commission elle propose de
ne pas les examiner ils ne sont pas
recevables et maintenant les sénateurs
vont voter sur cette motion
d'irrecevabilité alors que il y a
quelques minutes il y avait un débat
tendu après que la droite sénatoriale a
utilisé l'article 38 du Règlement du
Sénat pour clôturer les débats les
prises de parole de la gauche sur un
amendement qui concernait les maires de
famille on écoute le résultat de ce
scrutin public qui se termine du scrutin
public donc on le rappelle les sénateurs
qui votent sur leur tablette
électronique et le vote de sénateur est
donc rendu public sur cette motion
rendue publique sur le site internet du
Sénat on écoute le résultat
résultat du scrutin nombre de votes en
344 exprimé 344 pour 251 contre
93 le Sénat a adopté cette motion et
donc les deux amendements sont
irrécesvables donc un moment 2378 est
irrecevable et nous passons localement
dans 4431 la présidente assassy ou non
pardon
allez-y chers collègues merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur les ministres
chers collègues aujourd'hui les
exploitants agricoles où les employés
sont déjà plus de 20% à être en
incapacité dès leur première année de
retraite et 34% des ouvriers sont déjà
contraints dans les activités de la vie
quotidienne dès leur entrée à la
retraite
c'est la preuve s'il en était besoin que
l'allongement de la durée de la vie
n'est pas un argument pour justifier le
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite et cela est encore moins vrai
dans les territoires
ultra marins en effet l'espérance de vie
y est six années inférieures en moyenne
à celle des habitants de la métropole la
réforme doit donc tenir compte des
réalités se présente un moment souhaite
l'âge de l'âge de 64 ans pour un départ
à la retraite
ne soit pas pris en compte pour les
habitants de la Polynésie française nous
ne pouvons pas ajouter de l'inégalité à
l’inégalité touché à l'âge de départ à
la retraite risque de ne faire que
creuser des écarts les habitants
d'outre-mer méritent mieux que ça avec
cet amendement nous refusons donc
l'application de l'article 7 et de cette
réforme dans sa globalité aux habitants
de Polynésie française merci de votre
attention merci chers collègues et c'est
plusieurs sous amendements le 4768 qui
représente
pardon
[Musique]
c'est pareil sur 4769 allez-y
c'était un amendement
à la prise en compte des critères ou
droit au départ à la retraite par les
fonctionnaires résidents en Polynésie
française prévue par cette amendement il
semble préférable de prévoir un délai de
trois mois avant la prise en compte
d'intérêt ouvrant ce droit on fait comme
l'a dit tout à l'heure ma collègue
Raymond deponsemonge l'intérêt sur cet
article 7 c'était de discuter de la
brutalité de ce projet de loi et c'était
de discuter de ce que nous pouvions
effectivement proposer ou amender pour
le rendre moins brutal même si nous nous
souhaitons sa suppression voilà et donc
par les artifices que vous utilisez vous
nous empêchez de discuter de la
brutalité de ce projet de loi et des
conséquences qu'il aura sur des millions
de salariés dans ce pays
merci chers collègues donc le 4767
considère qui a été défendu il va l'être
il va l'être monsieur le président
c'est le président cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
dans le cadre d'un débat donc vous avez
sciemment dégradé la qualité et le
niveau
par les procédures que vous avez
choisies dans le règlement en
particulier je trouve personnellement
très très utile que c'est
sous-amendement nous permettent
d'évoquer les différentes catégories
socio-professionnelles de la population
française qui sont mis à mal par ce
projet de réforme des retraites uniques
et ces particules le cas avec cette
amendement 4767 qui vise à modifier le
critère de prise en compte de départ à
la retraite pour les fonctionnaires qui
résident en Polynésie française et de ne
tenir compte que de leur intérêt
matériel la notion d'intérêt moral qui
apparaît dans le dans le texte étant
pour le moins subjectif
chers collègues de 477
sous amendements
c'est le président
[Musique]
c'est le ministre mes chers je voudrais
profiter de ce sous amendement pour
attirer l'attention sur les
fonctionnaires d'État qui résident en
Polynésie française fonctionnaire d'État
ce sont des policiers sont les contrôles
les contrôleurs du trafic aérien ce sont
tout le personnel du Haut-Commissariat
vous le savez c'est fonctionnaires qui
sont en Polynésie française touchent une
bonification de salaire du fait de la
différence différentielle du coût de la
vie entre la France entre la métropole
entre la grille indiciaire de la de la
métropole et puis bien évidemment le
coût réel de la vie ce coup cette
différentielle il est de 84 de 0,84%.
c'est à dire que un fonctionnaire d'État
qui se trouve en Polynésie française a
un salaire de
1,84 par rapport à ce qu'il serait en
métropole pour tenir compte justement de
ce coup de la vie le fonctionnaire
français
paye des cotisations sur 1 84 or
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en 2008 le
ministre de l'époque qui s'appelait Yves
Jégo a considéré que l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite qui permettait
donc au retraites d'être majorée de 84 %
contenu du coût de la vie et bien que
c'était qu'il y avait des dérives on
appelait ça des retraites cocotiers
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y avait des
fonctionnaires d'une certaine façon qui
était en France et puis qui sont dit il
y a une bonification d'un 84 si je veux
en outre-mer donc je vais en profiter
donc il a dit et bien tout simplement on
le supprime sur 20 ans on le supprime
sur 20 ans ce qui fait que les
fonctionnaires d'État qui décident de
rester en Polynésie eux vont se trouver
dans une situation où le retraite va
être minorée par rapport au coût de la
vie donc il est important à travers ces
sous amendements de proposer donc des
mesures compensatoires sachant qu'il y a
une négociation qui est en cours avec
les le service du haut-commissaire pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que les
fonctionnaires d'État qui souhaitent
rester en Polynésie puisse avoir les
conditions de vie descente et le 477
défendu
4573 472
monsieur le ministre il faut que nous
prenions le temps quand même de pouvoir
intervenir
c'est amendement chers collègues
concerne la Polynésie française
et donc il est question dans ce texte de
pouvoir permettre une retraite des
fonctionnaires prévus par cet amendement
il semble préférable de prévoir un délai
de six mois avant la prise en compte des
intérêts ouvrant à ce droit merci
le 4773 oui
merci merci monsieur le Président donc
dans la suite donc tous ces amendements
portent sur la même thématique vous
l'avez compris mais sont importants
Jean-Michel Houlgate a très bien
expliqué quelle était la problématique
et ce délai effectivement de départ à la
retraite pour les fonctionnaires de
l'État résidant en Polynésie française
et justifiant bien sûr des intérêts
requis à notre avis doit être inférieur
à la durée qui a été prévue par les
auteurs de l'amendement et donc c'est
pour ça que on propose et on est ouvert
à une discussion évidemment avec avec la
commission avec leur rapporteur sur
cette question nous on propose de
diminuer ce délai par rapport à ce qu'il
est prévu actuellement et là en
l'occurrence l'amendement que je vous
présente prévoit de réduire ce délai au
lieu de deux années à un délai de neuf
mois je vous remercie
c'est durant
oui dans le droit fil des amendements
déposés et présentés par mes collègues
Houlgate et jaumier
cet amendement tend à s'intéresser à la
situation des fonctionnaires de l'État
résidant Polynésie française et
évidemment qui justifierait d'intérêt
requis nous estimons que
les auteurs de l'amendement prévoyant
deux ans pour ce retrait mériterait
d'étudier avec intérêt ce sous
amendement qui lui souhaite diminuer à
un an la période par rapport au
dispositif proposé
même sujet même
inquiétude
comme je l'ai dit à l'instant et comme
mes collègues Houlgate jaumier d'autres
collègues le long exposés c'est
amendement pour les fonctionnaires de
l'État résident en polynie-française et
qui justifie d'intérêt requis
propose de réduire de à 18 mois et non
pas deux ans la durée prévue
initialement dans le dispositif du
projet de loi merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur sur amendement
est sous amendement
oui merci effectivement cet amendement
mettre une distinction entre le régime
hexagonal et le régime des Outre-mer il
y a des propositions tout à fait
intéressantes c'est expliquer
effectivement le dispositif iTER est en
voie d'extinction
2028 monsieur le ministre nous précisera
exactement et c'est vrai que
actuellement c'est une majoration de
pensions et qu'il faut le prendre en
compte les
âges les agents anticipés de départ il y
en a déjà énormément cette réforme au
poste beaucoup de temps pour définir
effectivement un article 7 avec un âge
légal qui se décale à 64 ans mais on
passera aussi beaucoup d'articles pour
faire des dérogations et déjà anticipé
donc nous ne souhaitons pas nous le
souhaitons pas aller à l'encontre de la
philosophie de cette réforme qui n'est
pas celle d'agent anticiper mais plutôt
un effort collectif de durée du travail
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme sur
les autres demandes tout à l'heure je je
voudrais un avis défavorable et une
précision si vous le permettez Monsieur
le monsieur le
Président les sous amendements
effectivement mérite mérite une étude
approfondie parce que il faut voir
l'impact et en conséquence je ne peux
pas donner un avis de recevabilité tant
que la Commission ne s'est pas réunie en
ce qui concerne c'est sous amendements
donc avis défavorable sur l'amendement
et il recevabilité sur les sous
amendements
merci monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le Président en réalité sur
ces amendements vous donner des
explications très générales les
différences de coût de la vie entre les
territoires ultramarins et
métropolitains pour un sujet très
particulier que celui des fonctionnaires
en Polynésie d'abord sur l'amendement
qui vise la différencier l'effort
contributif qui est demandé à tous les
actifs du pays pour un principe d'équité
je suis défavorable et ensuite à travers
vos sous-amendements vous abordez en
réalité beaucoup de sujets qui ne sont
pas touchés par la réforme des retraites
qu'on est en train de discuter puisque
vous abordez en réalité deux sujets bien
particuliers celui des intérêts
matériels et moraux qui ne sont
absolument pas mis en cause ou toucher
ou impacté par la réforme que nous
sommes en train de discuter et celui de
l'indemnité temporaire de retraite qui
est une indemnité qui est mis en
extinction depuis 2008 qui n'a été
remise en cause par aucun des
gouvernements de toutes les majorités
dont les majorités socialistes dans les
quin qui ont précédé et qui n'a aucun
rapport direct avec la réforme des
retraites sur ces deux sujets ceci dit
pour ne pas répondre à côté j'ai déjà
répondu à une question au gouvernement
sur les intérêts matériels et moraux en
garantissant la bonne application
absolue des intérêts matériels émoraux
qui ont été définis par une
jurisprudence du Conseil d'État
extrêmement clairement et j'ai pris des
engagements puisque avec mon collège
Jean-François caraco je préside
effectivement une commission sur le
sujet particulier de l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite que nous
puissions trouver des mécanismes pour
apporter des réponses les élus
ultramarins qui participent à cette
commission elle a été réunie le 17
février dernier sur l'indemnité
temporaire de retraite le savent d'ici
le PLF de cette année nous aurons trouvé
des solutions pour venir trouver un
mécanisme dérogatoire à l'extinction qui
est encore une fois j'insiste sur ce
sujet n'a été remise en cause par aucun
des gouvernements depuis 2008 donc avis
défavorable surtout les amendements et
sous amendements merci monsieur le
rapporteur vous dire préciser quelque
chose une petite précision j'ai fait une
erreur j'ai parlé d'y recevabilité non
c'est un avis personnel défavorable en
ce qui concerne les sous amendements
puisqu’ils n'ont pas été émis étudié en
commission merci merci monsieur
le Président c'est un sujet que je
soulève depuis le début de notre
discussion ce texte ne tient aucun
compte des réalités outre-mer là vous
évoquez l'ITR indemnité temporaire de
retraite c'est pas seulement la
Polynésie c'est la Nouvelle-Calédonie
c'est Wallis-et-Futuna c'est la Réunion
c'est Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et un
régime un peu spécial pour la ça
n'existe pas en Guadeloupe en Martinique
et en Guyane il y a une mise en
extinction parce qu'il y avait des
fraudes personne n'a contesté un système
frauduleux on a donc réparé résultat les
engagements pris en 2008 commencez en
2019 l'État n'a jamais tenu compte des
compensations de l'intégration des
primes dans l'anciennes des
rémunérations et que les économies
faites resteraient dans le territoire
résultat des militaires sont en pauvreté
les fonctionnaires d'État sont en
pauvreté et vous dites ça n'est pas ça
impacte et quand vous avez ici les
documents de la CNAV c'est vrai en
Martinique en couper ailleurs la pension
de retraite en Martinique le régime
général c'est 540 euros c'est des
carrières hachées pour obtenir le
minimum contributif il faut 120
trimestres chez nous on obtient pas sans
distrimètre ce qui fait sa tombe sur les
femmes cette retraite ce projet est
kafkaïen surréaliste et ignore et vous
nous invoquez l'Iron sauvabilité au nom
du traitement inégal ou différent des
territoires il faut plus de
différenciation pour mieux tenir compte
des réalités c'est fou ce que vous
faites merci euh chers collègues
monsieur Durand
oui monsieur le Président je souscris
aux arguments qui ont été développés par
notre collègue Victoria Lurel juste un
petit point de méthode j'ai bien compris
que tout ce débat vous agaçait
prodigieusement que tout ça est beaucoup
trop lentement et qu'il fallait
accélérer dans tact vous ne voulez pas
de la main tendue ou de vous offrons
pour vous aider à vous sortir du guêpier
dans lequel vous vous êtes fourré en
vous embarquant dans cette loi aussi mal
fagotée vous ne voulez pas nous nous
laissez vous aider à sortir de
l'impopularité qui ne va falloir assumer
partout dans chaque ville village
préfecture sous préfecture mais si vous
voulez gagner du temps je pense qu'on
gagnerait quand même à avoir des deux
rouleurs qui sont un petit peu
correctement ficelés on a un dérouleur
papier sur lequel n'apparaissent pas les
amendements qu'on vient étudier on a un
tableau électronique qui mentionne des
amendements dans un ordre et on a un
dérouleur numérique qui mentionne un
ordre différent de ce qu'on a là donc un
tout petit peu de méthode nous aidera à
vous aider à aller beaucoup beaucoup
plus vite
merci chers collègues et Madame pour ces
Monges
merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez retiré
le recours à lire recevabilité mais en
fait je pense que vous allez peut-être
l'actionner un peu plus tard j'avais
demandé tout à l'heure la parole après
les propos du monsieur de monsieur le
ministre mais vous m'avez pas vu donc
j'en profite pour dire à Monsieur le
Ministre du socle si vous prétendez au
nom de la séparation des pouvoirs ne pas
vous mêler désirsovabilité
décréter notamment par le Sénat
je vous demande d'aller jusqu'au bout et
de vous abstenir de les commenter et
surtout en reprenant les mêmes exemples
que monsieur le rapporteur
en les commentant vous ne respectez pas
la séparation des pouvoirs et beaucoup
plus grave pour vous nous pourrions
croire que vous les avez inspiré
et Monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre et
chers collègues défend l'amendement 44
31 monsieur le rapporteur vous avez usé
hier mais on n'a pas eu le temps d'avoir
le débat parce que l'article 38 a été
déclenché autour de l'espérance de vie
et
l'amendement que nous déposons vient ici
ayez de le contredire nous vivons plus
longtemps donc il faut travailler plus
longtemps j'essaie de ne pas caricaturer
vos propos mais c'était à peu près ça
oui mais sur le rapporteur pourquoi on
vit plus longtemps
et oui c'est la question il y a la
question la santé publique qui a
beaucoup progressé la question de la
vaccination
la question l'alimentation du progrès
technique la robotisation
notamment au travail qui permet de
gagner de l'espérance de vie et de
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé et
puis il y a eu des lois
plus protectrices pour les travailleurs
et travailleurs au début du siècle on
travaille 10 heures six jours par
semaine bon ben on a atteint un moment
donné les congés payés la journée des
huit heures et puis évidemment les 35
heures le partage du temps de travail
donc si on revient et qu'on est à rebond
de l'histoire à un moment donné on aura
un problème sur la question l'espérance
de vie deuxième argument si nous gagnons
l'espérance de vie pourquoi le donner
qu'au capital
c'est une question on peut le partager
là aussi à un moment donné avec du temps
libéré des contrats du capital et donc
un droit à la retraite pour être utile
autrement et dernière argument sur
lequel vous n'avez jamais répondu en 5
jours oui oui espérance de vie bien sûr
on travaille moins mais on est beaucoup
plus productif que dans les années 80 là
où elle salarié générée 25000 euros de
travail de valeur il en fait 80 000
aujourd'hui et les gains de productivité
sont passés où dans le travail dans les
salaires dans les pensions
j'aimerais la réponse de monsieur le
rapporteur merci beaucoup chers
collègues donc j'ai été saisi de scrutin
public sur ces sous amendements et sur
l'amendement en lui-même
donc je vais soumettre au scrutin public
le sous amendement 4768 avec deux avis
défavorables
de ce que tu as ouvert
vous pouvez rester près des et les
sénateurs qui votent actuellement dans
ce débat sur la réforme des retraites
sur des amendements qui concernent
précisément à des fonctionnaires
résidents en Polynésie française des
amendements qui prévoit des
bonifications de leurs droits à la
retraite pour ces fonctionnaires
contenus et bien du coup de la vie
notamment sur les territoires de la
pollinisée de la Polynésie française il
est donc un scrutin public actuellement
elle est sénateurs qui votent sur leur
tablette électronique et le vote de
chaque sénateur sera rendu public sur le
site du Sénat sur le site internet du
Sénat des débats donc des amendements
sur les fonctionnaires en Polynésie
après et bien un passage où le dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat puisque la droite
c'est notoriale a une nouvelle fois
utilisé l'article 38 du Règlement du
Sénat pour clôturer les débats sur des
amendements qui concernaient les maires
de familles des amendements qui
prévoyaient de pour ces mères de famille
et bien qu'elle puisse garder les
trimestres gagner grâce à leur
parentalité et donc la clôture de ces
débats a forcément mis en rogne la
gauche on écoute le résultat de ce que
tu as publié
344 exprimé 343 pour 93 contre 250 il
n'est pas adopté sur sous-amendement
4767 de ce que tu as ouvert
et pendant que les sénateurs procèdent
au scrutin public sur ces amendements
qui concernent les fonctionnaires
résidents pollinisés françaises on a
retrouvé Quentin Calmet en tribune de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin on assiste
là dans cette fin d'après-midi à des
débats au Sénat sur courant alternatifs
autour de cette réforme des retraites
oui oui c'est un rythme très étrange
ajoutez à cela les problèmes techniques
sur le fait que tous les Allemands sont
mal affichés entre le site du Sénat et
effectivement les écrans dans
l'hémicycle il en fallait pas moins pour
que et bien les débats soient houleux
dans l'hémicycle déjà que c'est
compliqué avec la gauche sénatoriale qui
a perdu un millier de sous amendements
entre hier et aujourd'hui et qui voit
donc c'est possible de s'opposer à
l'article 7 réduit comme peau de chagrin
plus ajouter à cela depuis quelques
minutes et bien l'utilisation de
l'article 38 qui a été redemandé sur un
amendement par le chef de fil des LR et
donc la limitation du nombre d'orateurs
sur un amendement une personne peut
présenter son amendement deux orateurs
pour et ensuite c'est tout et bien tout
cela ajoute à une forme voilà de tension
qui est présente dans l'hémicycle qui
n'est pas propice au débat sur le fond
je peux vous l'assurer à tout moment on
sent qu'une braise peut enflammer ce
débat alors que effectivement on
commence tout juste à aller sur certains
points techniques du fond voilà on va
écouter effectivement le président de
séance Vincent Delaive qui va pouvoir
proclamer les résultats de ce scrutin
votant 332 exprimer 331 pour 81 contre
250 pas adopté le 477
de ce que tu as ouvert
votant 343 4 exprimés 343 pour 93 contre
250 il n'a pas été adopté 4771 de ce que
tu as ouvert
et les sénateurs qui poursuivent c'est
votre sur les scrutins publics qui ont
été demandés autour d'amendement qui
concerne et bien l'âge de départ à la
retraite de fonctionnaires résident en
polyn française on va retrouver Quentin
calmé en tribune de l'hémicycle du Sénat
quand un rappel nous ce que c'est
inscrit un public dans la procédure
parlementaire oui d'autant que c'est
l'une des dernières armes qu'il reste en
fait encore à la gauche pour ralentir ce
débats tout simplement pour résumer et
bien au lieu de voter à main levée sur
un amendement on voit on va sur des
machines de vote dans l'hémicycle les
machines vont être électroniques avec
ensuite le résultat qui s'inscrit sur
les écrans géants qui se trouve ici sur
les bords sur les murs qui jouxtent
l'hémicycle comme cela alors les
sénateurs votent tous avec leur carte
électromagnétique ou alors il y a une
délégation de vote qui est accordée au
président des groupes ou un
vice-président qui dans ces cas-là
rassemble les cartes magnétiques de tous
les ordinateur membre de son vote et il
se met à l'avance d'accord sur qui vote
quoi sur tel amendement tel article et
donc avec la délégation de vote un
président ou un vice-président de groupe
va voter pour l'ensemble du groupe c'est
ce qui fait que l'on a un nombre de
votants qui est bien supérieur au nombre
de présence dans l'hémicycle c'est
permis que par le Règlement du Sénat ça
n'existe plus depuis les années 90 à
l'Assemblée nationale où vous ne pouvez
voter que avec une seule délégation de
vote pour 1 seul député à votre place et
donc ça c'est ce qui permet au sénateur
bien de s'exprimer avec l'ensemble de
l'hémistique merci beaucoup Quentin pour
ces explications tu écoutes les
résultats
contre 250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons 477
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est
votant 344 exprimé 343 pour 93 contre
250 pas adopter 474
voilà et pendant que les sénateurs
votent par scrutin public sur ses
amendements j'accueille sur ce plateau
David à Soline bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de Paris un mot sur
la reprise de ces débats cet après-midi
sur l'article 7 de la réforme des
retraites il y a toujours beaucoup de
tension entre la gauche et la droite
sénatoriale oui bon d'abord ce qui s'est
passé cette nuit ça laisse des traces
mais on pensait au moins sur les
amendements qui restent en discussion et
qui ont été remis à la discussion par la
Commission elle-même après en avoir et
la guerre des centaines et des milliers
on va dire que le débat allait quand
même avoir lieu sur ce minimum et sur le
premier amendement du groupe socialiste
qui est qui avait passé
tous ces filtrage on nous remet
l'article 38 qui n'a quasiment jamais
été utilisé au Sénat jusqu'à présent
pour dire il y a juste un pour un conte
et pas de droit d'explication de votre
c'est la démonstration de ce que l'on
disait parce que je voit bien que la
droite est en train de dire j'avais
obstruction parce qu'ils avaient des
centaines d'amendements etc et donc on a
utilisé des moyens de faire que le débat
soit sérieux réel sur l'essentiel mais
là c'est le l'essentiel justement
puisqu'ils ont déjà tout balancé dans la
nuit et il remettent l'article 38 c'est
incroyable d'autant que à l'Assemblée
nationale l'article 7 beaucoup sont
fusqués n'a pas été discuté or c'est
l'article de la loi c'est il y a pas de
loi sur cet article c'est c'est c'est là
que on dit qu'on passe à 64 ans ce qui
est l'objet de la contestation de des
Français et quand on arrive ici le Sénat
peut sonorer lui d'avoir ce débat parce
que si la loi est adoptée entre
guillemets avec toutes les méthodes
expédiatives du gouvernement faudra bien
quand même cet article et eu un débat
dans une des deux chambres il n'a pas eu
lieu à l'Assemblée
on a eu 50 heures déjà de discussion ici
sur ce qui était disons secondaire dans
la loi même si rien n'est secondaire
mais sur cet article ils sont en train
d'aller à marche forcée et ne pas
vouloir de débat et donc ce n'est pas
pour lutter contre l'abstant
l'obstruction de la gauche que le la
droite est en train d'utiliser ces
méthodes mais bien pour empêcher le
débat sur la tigre fondamentale
l'article 7 donc vous reconnaissez qu'il
y a une forme d'obstruction à la gauche
et que l'objectif de la gauche
sénatoriale c'est d'empêcher un vote
final c'est l'inverse je ne reconnais
pas je suis en train de vous dire que
sur l'article 7 sur la chaîne
je suis en train de vous dire je vous
dis que nous voulons un débat et un vote
sur l'article 7 et un débat approfondie
parce que c'est le ne de cette réforme
d'accord et que c'est paradoxalement sur
cet article que les foudres se sont
déchaînés de la droite pour empêcher
qu'il soit débat voilà donc le débat
devient quasi insensaire si aucune des
deux assemblées discutait sur le fond de
cet article même une CMP bon le Conseil
constitutionnel va devoir se pencher sur
le fait que le nœud de cette réforme n'a
pas été délibéré réellement et
sincèrement dans les assemblées après
nous on sait que le gong tombe le
dimanche à 23h oui ça c'est le
gouvernement qui est utilisé cette cette
méthode qui est que notre temps est
contraint il doit s'arrêter là et vous
avez ramené pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
votre finale
on va on va tout faire pour se battre et
faire que cette réforme ne soit pas
adoptée j'ai pas je suis pas
notre objectif c'est que cette loi soit
battue tout simplement mais aujourd'hui
nous empêche de discuter de l'article
phare et c'est ça le sujet d'aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup David Assouline d'être
venu sur le plateau de Public Sénat
allez on retourne dans l'hémicycle
suivant si je dépasse légèrement mon
temps mais je n'en suis pas sûr
simplement c'est un ces amendements que
ce soit le 4146 et les quatre suivants
reprennent alinéa paralinéa les durées
les durées de cotisation qui sont
augmentées progressivement par âge de
génération en génération et tant mieux
ces progressif c'est pas brutalement
comme on peut l'entendre on prend deux
ans non on prend pas deux ans c'est un
trimestre par année de génération ce qui
montre bien qu'il y a une progression
alors effectivement on peut faire des
sous amendements s'opposer à cela et
supprimer être pas d'accord avec ça mais
on peut aussi avoir une technique qui
consiste alinéa paralinéa à proposer à
supprimer les 160 69 trimestres pour une
certaine génération
170 pour une autre génération etc
voyez-vous je pense que c'est pas
forcément ça qui va faire avancer le
débat dès l'instant où vous êtes opposé
et nous y sommes favorables par contre
par contre Monsieur Game a une question
qui me semble-t-il est intéressante la
productivité voilà là ça mérite un débat
la productivité en France elle est
meilleure qu'ailleurs et bien qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire que les conditions de
travail sont pas si mauvaises que ça ça
veut dire que nos employeurs ça veut
dire que nos employés nos salariés nos
travailleurs et bien quelque part ils
travaillent mieux que dans les pays
voisins ça mérite d'être souligné quand
même c'est pas le temps boulot misérable
que l'on a parfois entendu ces derniers
jours mais se posent monsieur gay il y a
pas que la productivité il y a également
le problème de la population qui fait un
bassin et les heures travaillées en
France 630 heures par an ramené à
l'habitant le pays voisin madame
chilinger vous le connaissez bien c'est
à quelques centaines de mètres de chez
vous
940 heures 630 940 on voit bien qu'il y
a des pays qui ont une conception
différente du travail je pense que ça
méritait d'être de signaler et comme
nous avons comme nous avons justement
pas suffisamment de production parce que
nous n'avons pas suffisamment d'heures
travaillées pour conforter notre modèle
social il nous appartient de prendre nos
responsabilités c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous demandons cet effort
collectif pour travailler plus
globalement à la fois pour produire
davantage et faire en sorte que nos
jeunes puissent trouver du travail mais
également améliorer l'équilibre de la
réforme des retraites
merci monsieur le Président l'amendement
présenté par Madame pour sopolis
supprime un alinéa de l'article il y en
a trois autres qui suivent qui suivent
les qui suppriment les alinés
impressionnants cela remet en cause la
montée en puissance de la réforme dit
Touraine donc le Gouvernement est
favorable à cet amendement numéro 41 46
comme nous serons des favorable
exactement pour les mêmes raisons pour
les trois suivants je serai plus rapide
madame la sénatrice vous avez
interpellé en disant la France qui vous
a élu il se trouve que la France qui m'a
élu c'est une circonscription du Nord de
l'Ardèche et c'est plus particulièrement
une commune
vous avez dit vous avez dit Monsieur le
Ministre donc j'ai bien pensé que vous
vous adressiez à moi et je vous dis
simplement madame la sénatrice que c'est
donc une circonscription au nord de
l'Ardèche et c'est plus particulièrement
une commune qui s'appelle Annonay qui
est cher à mon coeur puisque j'y est né
j'ai grandi et j'y habite et hier de 10h
à 15h 10h 15h un tiers des foyers ont
été privés d'électricité à la suite
d'une coupure sauvage et volontaire dans
le cadre du mouvement social sont des
écoles confirmées ce sont des personnes
hospitalisées à domicile sous
respirateur quand tu es mise en danger
ce sont des personnes coincées dans des
ascenseurs ce sont des commerces fermés
des restaurants qui n'ont pas pu ouvrir
c'est cette France là que je pense quand
j'ai foncé très fort
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le rapporteur de la réponse on
peut continuer à avoir un débat même si
il sera court mais vous avez pas répondu
sur les gains de productivité vous nous
avez répondu sur la pénibilité et il y a
des métiers difficiles moins difficiles
c'est vrai que le travail à l'usine est
moins pénible aujourd'hui qu'il y a 50
ans mais il peut rester des métiers
extrêmement difficiles y compris à
l'usine sur les chantiers j'ai pas vu
beaucoup d'exosquelette quand j'en
visite mais peut-être demain ou
après-demain ça va exister mais vous
avez pas répondu sur les gains de
productivité
un salarié en 1980 généré 25000 euros de
richesse créée aujourd'hui 80 000 où
sont passés ces gains de productivité ni
dans les salaires ni dans les pensions
de retraite et il y a 10 points donc je
vous réponds 10 points étaient volés par
le capital au travail est-ce qu'on est
d'accord ou pas c'est le rapporteur non
mais attendez ça c'est pas c'est pas moi
ou le groupe communiste ou l'ensemble de
la gauche c'est les chiffres fondés non
mais je vous dis ça et donc il faut bien
qu'on ait un débat sur cette question où
est la gaine productivité sur la
productivité horaire on vous a déjà
répondu
l'ouvrier français et un des plus
productifs y compris par rapport à
l'Allemagne et d'ailleurs c'est le
rapporteur je vous le dis là aussi si
votre vision c'est les jobs à 1 euro et
les travailleurs pauvres c'est pas la
nôtre et si votre vision c'est d'avoir
des retraités pauvres comme en Allemagne
ou contrairement à la France où il y a
déjà trop c'est trop 10% de retraité
pauvre mais 21,5 en Allemagne si c'est
ça la société dans laquelle vous voulez
vivre pour nous c'est long je vous le
dis donc c'est le rapporteur je vous
demande de re répondre à la question
pour vous où sont passés les gains de
productivité et comment mieux les
partager je vous remercie c'est chers
collègues et le président Patriat
demande la parole
c'est le Président je vous remercie je
demande l'application de l'article 38 un
pour rencontre
donc j'ai une demande d'application
d'article 38 à nouveau donc il y a un
orateur par groupe qui peut s'exprimer
un orateur pas gros madame pour ses
Monges
allez-y madame pour ces Monges
mais est-ce que ça signifie je suis
contre bien sûr 38 qu'on va pas pouvoir
commenter ce qui a été dit précédemment
bon alors moi je vais les commenter du
coup voilà alors monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez du mal à voir qui fera 2 ans
de plus bon alors je vous dis les femmes
les femmes à 62 ans pile à 62 ans piles
sont plus nombreuses que les hommes à
liquider leur retraite elles sont 35%,
35% des femmes liquides leur retraite à
62 ans pile pour ces 35% de femmes ces
deux enferment
je vous ai déjà signalé mais bon que à
61 ans une personne sur deux plus d'une
personne sur deux n'est pas en emploi
n'est plus en emploi mais
au minima sociaux au chômage de longue
durée en maladie de longue durée en
inactivité quelquefois sans ressource
cela à 61 ans c'est pour eux ils
pouvaient partir à 62 ans sortir de ces
minimas pour liquider leur retraite pour
eux ces deux ans ferment
c'est ça qu'il faut quand tu es quand on
vient de productivité j'ai peut-être pas
le temps mais ils sont quand on voit
l'intensité de travail etc quelques fois
ils sont faits sur une base
d'intensification du travail et de
souffrance au travail donc ils sont pas
tous vertueux les gains de productivité
merci pour ces moments
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres chers collègues juste je
défends cet amendement mais juste pour
revenir sur les gains de productivité il
est évident que on l'a déjà dit que que
cette retraite par répartition elle est
aussi elle doit être aussi la
répartition de la richesse produite par
le travail mais d'ailleurs je sais plus
si c'est Michel Édouard Leclerc qui a
dit à un moment donné qu'il faudrait
taxer les robots parce que si on pousse
à l'extrême dans l'hypothèse où on est
une société totalement automatisée et où
il n'y a plus personne qu'il cotise
parce que personne ne travaille ou n'est
productif c'est une situation absurde
mais mais il faut se poser la question
de savoir justement sur où sont répartis
les gains de productivité je reviens sur
je reviens sur l'amendement en question
pourquoi nous le soutenons tout
simplement parce que cette réforme elle
est brutale elle est brutale elle génère
des frustrations et on l'a vu s'il y a
une s'il y a une mobilisation de cette
ampleur c'est aussi parce que les gens
sont frustrés pourquoi le sont-ils tout
simplement parce que les gens qui sont
nés en 1961 il se projette et il se
projette d'autant plus qu'il reçoive
régulièrement est-ce qu'on appelle le
relevé individuel de situation et on l'a
tous reçu se relever individuel de
situation et en plus à côté de ce relevé
individuel de situation et bien on
reçoit ce qu'on appelle une Estimation
Indicative Globale et bien avec ça les
gens se projettent ils se disent ben oui
il me reste encore temps de trimestre à
faire et peut-être même que je dois
faire un peu plus compte tenu de
l'ajustement que je fais par rapport à
cette Estimation Indicative Globale
parce que c'est pas suffisant et que je
serai amené à me caler peut-être un peu
plus longtemps mais toujours est-il que
que les gens se projettent et à partir
du moment où de façon brutale on leur
dit ben écoutez vous allez travailler un
trimestre deux ou trois de plus et bien
elle vit évidemment ça génère des
frustrations parce que les gens ont des
projets individuels alors se posent la
question se pose la question du rapport
au travail mais j'aurais eu l'occasion
de leur développer dans d'autres
interventions et chers collègues
je vais mettre aux voix donc
l'application de l'article 38 qui est
pour l'application de l'article 38
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté et donc
nous passons au vote et j'ai demandé de
scrutin public de la part du groupe CCE
sur l'amendement 4146 avec deux avis
défavorables donc il va être procédé au
scrutin public le scrutin est ouvert
Chine les sénateurs qui continuent le
débat sur l'article 7 de cette réforme
des retraites un article qui porte l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
et c'est aussi un article qui accélère
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
elle était prévue depuis la réforme
torrent souffrance Hollande et bien à 43
annuités en 2035 et cette réforme des
retraites prévoient de passer ces 43
évanités à 2027 donc une accélération de
l'augmentation et ces amendements
communistes qui sont en train d'être
votés par scrutin public en ce moment
justement il supprime cette accélération
de l'augmentation de la durée de
cotisation allez on va retrouver Quentin
Calmet en tribune dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat au Quentin l'article 38 du
Règlement du Sénat a été une nouvelle
fois utilisée mais cette fois-ci par un
sénateur de la majorité présidentielle
exactement alors que les amendements des
communistes viennent d'être rejetés et
que donc c'est la gauche qui s'opposait
à cette accélération de la réforme
Touraine est en train de perdre les
arbitrage par le vote on va écouter
Laurence Cohen effectivement puisque
maintenant il y a l'article 38 qui est
aussi demandé par François patriar va
suivre ça de très près 1963 c'est un peu
ce qu'a dit notre notre rapporteur qui a
bien compris le sens de nos amendements
en 2013 nous avons combattu la réforme
Touraine au niveau du groupe communiste
nous considérons naturellement son
accélération comme l'approfondissement
d'une logique mortifère pour les
travailleurs et les travailleuses en
portant la durée de cotisation à 170
trimestres dès la génération 1963 vous
ne prenez pas en compte les réalités du
travail il existe pour de nombreux
Français français une zone grise plus ou
moins longue très inconfortable où les
femmes et les hommes ne sont ni en
emploi ni à la retraite c'était le cas
de près de 16,7% des personnes âgées de
62 ans 2021 dont 3% étaient au chômage
et 13,7% en inactivité et dépendait
essentiellement du RSA d'une pension
d'invalidité ou du revenu de leur
conjoint le taux d'emploi des plus de 60
ans est faible 35,5 % contre 46,4 % au
sein de l'Union européenne plus on
avance en âge moins on a de chance
d'avoir un emploi surtout si l'on n'a
pas décroché de titre scolaires là je
constitue avec le sexe le premier motif
déclaré des expériences de
discrimination liées au travail loin
devant l'origine ethnique pointait en
2018 France stratégie allongez donc la
durée de cotisation ne peut que
pénaliser l'ensemble des travailleurs de
la génération de 1963 d'où la
suppression de l'alinéa et monsieur le
Président vous avez vu j'ai pas joué sur
le chrono qui s'était pas déclenché
merci même quand monsieur rapporteur
vous avez donné vis-à-vis des favorable
monsieur le ministre aussi il y a deux
avis défavorables donc j'ai saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public sur cet
amendement par le groupe CRCE
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
expliqué en
argumentant sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements que c'était après tout
l'application strict de l'accélération
de la durée de cotisation circuler il y
a rien à voir moi je voudrais vous
parler d'un cas particulier qui montre
en effet la brutalité de cette réforme
je vais vous parler d'un jardinier qui
travaille dans la une ville de
Seine-Maritime qui est dirigé par un
ancien Premier ministre qui est
favorable à la retraite à 67 ans je
pense que vous suivez que vous
identifiez ce jardinier l'exerce depuis
81 il est exposé aux postures pénibles
aux risques chimiques aux vibrations au
gestes répétitifs et me dit-il à
l'accroissement des surfaces à traiter
puisqu'il y a visiblement eu dans cette
ville des réductions d'effectifs
lorsqu'il contact la RH en charge des
retraites il apprend qu'une personne née
en juin 63 peut bénéficier du dispositif
carrière longue mais que lui qui est né
en septembre 63 va devoir travailler 9
mois de plus j'ai rencontré ce jardinier
dans une manifestation parce qu'il
portait une pancarte où était indiquée
42 ans de bonnes conduite 9 mois ferme
et donc les amendements que nous
proposons tout en vous le savez nous
contestons fondamentalement
l'allongement et l'accélération de la
durée de cotisation mais il y a des
situations particulières qui
mériteraient d'être prises en compte
parce que des gens se retrouvent dans
des situations extrêmement difficiles
dans les prochains mois merci chers
collègues donc je mets au vote cet
amendement j'ai demandé de scrutin
public par le groupe CRCE sur cet
amendement 4149 avec deux avis
défavorables
le scrutin est ouvert
et les qui continuent à voter sur des
amendements sur l'article 7 de la
réforme des retraites qui allongent
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite et
qui accélèrent l'augmentation de la
durée de cotisation on va retrouver
Quentin calmer faites-nous un petit
point sur les débats sur cet article 7
effectivement c'est des bases sur
l'article 7 qui ont repris après les
questions d'actualité c'était à 16h30
avec un faux rythme depuis 16h30 on a
beaucoup des bêtises au début et bien de
la perte de ses amendements par la
gauche hier en séance ensuite on discute
un peu sur le fond puis ensuite on
discute à nouveau sur la méthode car et
bien l'intervalle régulier on voit
d'abord monsieur Retailleau puis ensuite
François Patriat pour les marcheurs du
Sénat demandez l'utilisation de
l'article 38 qui contraint le nombre de
prises de paroles dans la défense ou
dans l'opposition un amendement donc il
y a à la fois un débat sur le fond mais
qui est entrecoupé avec un débat sur la
méthode et c'est des va contraint
effectivement par le Règlement du Sénat
retour au débat
je peux partir au même âge à 58 et avec
43 unités si je commence à travailler à
16 ans je peux partir à 60 ans mais avec
44 habités mais si c'est 17 ans c'est
toujours 60 ans mais avec 43 nuités bref
et ça s'enchaîne comme ça jusqu'à l'âge
de 21 ans et donc on a du mal à voir
comment vous avez construit ce tableau
et qu'est-ce qu'il y a de juste à ce que
lorsqu'on a travaillé commencé à
travailler à 14 c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose qu'à 15 et pourquoi il faut
que je cotise plus pour partir au même
âge je vous remercie monsieur le
Président merci chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
simplement je vais mettre un avis
défavorable et symbole exemple parce que
actuellement votre personne qui a
travaillé avant 16 ans si elle a 4 à
saint-primès avant la fin de ses 16 ans
elle va partir combien quelle est la
durée de cotisation quelle est la durée
de cotisation d'art + 2 d'art + 2 ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire 45 ans ça
c'est l'application de la loi actuelle
qui a voté cette loi
pardon pas vous vous avez voté cette loi
qu'est-ce qu'il est proposé dans la loi
qui vient que ces personnes qui ont
Catastro trimestre avant la fin de la
saison de la fin de l'année de leur
saison excusez-moi puisse travailler
moins longtemps et on aura l'occasion de
discuter avec ça c'est l'article 8 parce
qu'effectivement il y a un certain
nombre d'inégalités parce qu'à un mois
près vous tapez la bande suivante et en
conséquence vous prenez effectivement la
2 ans ça mérite un débat voilà ça mérite
un débat on l'aura dans l'article 8
vivement qu'on y soit l'article 8
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
c'est la vie défavorable que j'ai déjà
exprimé j'ajoute à ce que dit monsieur
le rapporteur que pour pouvoir partir
dans le cadre des dispositifs carrière
longue il ne suffit pas d'avoir quatre
ou cinq trimestres cotisés avant la
dernière jour de l'année civile de vos
saisons de vos 18 ans demain ou de vos
20 ans il faut avoir les 4 à 5
trimestres cotisées avant la borne d'âge
il faut atteindre l'âge d'ouverture des
droites telles que prévu par la loi
c'est à dire 58 ans si vous avez
commencé avant 16 ans dans la loi
aujourd'hui et il faut par ailleurs
avoir atteint la durée de cotisation
requise en l'état de la loi la Dar + 2
intégralement cotisée sans tenir compte
des trimestres qui ne serait que valider
et cotisés ce qui explique qu'entre les
principes de départ au titre des
carrières longues et la bonification
effective il y a un écart parce que bien
souvent dans la carrière des uns et des
autres tous les tous les trimestres
arrivaient à l'âge légal ne sont pas des
trimestres cotisées mais une partie
peuvent être validées le service
militaire par exemple et ce qui explique
les décalages ce qui rend assez
inopérant pardon de le dire comme ça les
comparaisons de Data ou d'anniversaire à
anniversaire puisqu'en réalité ça
renvoie au parcours de vie de chacun
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe CRCE sur cet amendement
4285 avec deux avis défavorables il va
être procédé au scrutin public le
scrutin est ouvert
et les sénateurs qui continuent à voter
et à discuter de l'article 7 de cette
réforme des retraites un article qui je
le rappelle augmente l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans et puis autre mesure
dans cette article 7 il accélère la
réforme Touraine qui avait été votée
sous François Hollande c'est une réforme
qui augmentait progressivement la durée
de cotisation nécessaire jusqu'en 2035
pour attendre pour atteindre 43 à nuités
et cette réforme dans le second
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron et bien
elle accélère cette augmentation de la
durée de cotisation pour atteindre ces
43 à nuités en 2027 et là ce que propose
des sénateurs communistes avec leurs
amendements c'est d'exonérer de cette
augmentation de cotisation certaines
générations notamment dans les années
1960 il y en a vu défavorable on a
entendu du gouvernement et de la
commission alors que le scrutin public
est bientôt clos sur ce nouvel
amendement communiste autour de la durée
de cotisations alors on le rappelle il y
a un petit un petit jeu de procédure la
gauche qui multiplie les scrutin public
pour rallonger un petit peu les débats
on écoute le résultat 344 exprimé 343
pour 93 contre 250 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté nous passerons 4286 qui le défend
allez-y madame
merci monsieur le Président à l'instant
nous avons échangé en vue de la
suppression de l'article 7 qui est le
cœur de notre contreforme sociale à
défaut d'avoir pu supprimer tout cet
article nous nous attacherons donc à
retirer le du texte ce qui nous semble
le plus problématique l'allongement de
l'âge légal de départ en retraite les
alinéosités dans notre amendement sont
précisément ce qui décaleront demain
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans pour pouvoir
partir en retraite et partant de là
allongeront pour tous les Français les
carrières de deux ans on a eu l'occasion
d'en discuter longuement mais selon les
chiffres de la DARES publiés en janvier
2023 pour l'année 2021 le constat est
infligent malgré 6 ans au pouvoir votre
gouvernement n'a pas réussi à enrayer le
chômage des 55 ans et plus aujourd'hui
la frontière des 60 ans se matérialise
par une chute d'activité de 68% à 59 ans
vers 43% à 61 ans pour atteindre 15% à
64 ans en reculant l'âge les légales de
la retraite vous créez une trappe de
pauvreté dont les Français de plus de 55
ans qui perdent leur emploi ne pourront
pas s'en sortir la réforme de
l'indemnisation invalidité joue elle
aussi contre les travailleurs je ne
citerai qu'un seul exemple celui d'un
couple de boulanger de mon département
elle a un cancer lui a des problèmes
cardiaques après des années à maintenir
coûte que coûte une activité ils ont
fini par vendre leur atelier or avec les
nouveaux modes de calcul des pensions
d'invalidité il ne touche plus que 900
euros à deux
âgé de 58 et 60 ans comment vont-ils
vivre ces prochaines années corothil
comme retraite comme tous les artisans
et commerçants de notre pays leur outil
de travail et le patrimoine de toute une
vie il pensait l'utiliser fièrement pour
l'avenir de leur enfant les études des
petits-enfants et bien non comme de
nombreux travailleurs qui ont réussi à
mettre un peu de côté votre réforme va
les dévaliser et pendant ce temps-là les
fraudeurs aux cotisations sociales les
évad fiscaux les profiteurs de la crise
dorment sur leurs deux oreilles reculez
[Musique]
de parler des invalidité très bien
monsieur le ministre même avis mais ma
vie donc monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues une des
questions là aussi que sur lequel vous
n'avez pas répondu on vient d'avoir le
débat enfin on n'a pas eu de réponse sur
quel productivité on essaie de continuer
à prendre argument par argument parce
que un débat c'est ça on pose une
question vous répondez on ressort un
contre argument on épuise le truc voilà
et puis à un moment donné il y en a un
qui marque un point bon pour l'instant
on n'a pas été au bout quoi bon on a
marqué beaucoup de poèmes bon mais c'est
vous qui maîtrisez le match
sur comme ça mais nous on respecte le
règlement à la lettre une des questions
une des questions sur le rapporteur
c'est que vous allez décaler la borne de
l'âge légal de 62 à 64 ans et donc c'est
une question vous allez le mettre et le
placer sur l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé et une des questions dans le sur
lesquelles il faut parler et à partir de
la réalité du vécu des gens c'est pas
grave à chaque fois qu'on parle du vécu
des gens j'entendais ah mais on est bien
là pour parler du vécu des gens et donc
quand on déplace la borne de 62 à 64 ans
qui est la borne de l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé ça veut dire qu'ensemble
enfin nous non mais vous faites le choix
de placer la borne pour la moitié des
gens ils partiront pas à la retraite en
bonne santé et c'est quand même une
question
pour nous nous pensons qu'après une dure
vie de labeur et le travail source
d'émancipation elle est un social mais
aussi de souffrance physique et
psychique on pense qu'il faut vivre une
retraite pendant des années au moins en
bonne santé parce que si on place la
borne au moment de l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé on connaît un certain nombre
de personnes notamment de métier où les
gens ils ne profitent pas de la retraite
parce que on ne profite pas quand on
tombe malade de suite et qu'après
pendant deux ans on est entre les
rendez-vous médicaux et l'hôpital donc
il faut bien qu'on ait ce débat là je
vous remercie monsieur le Président
merci chers collègues le président rénal
oui moi je reconnais que ces évocations
de personnes touchées par les réformes
sont difficiles à entendre on le
comprend bien mais en même temps c'est
bien ça la réalité et ce débat est
passionnant de ce point de vue là il
faut effectivement sortir ici de la
théorie il faut voir ce que nous faisons
et comment ça se traduit pour les uns
pour les autres et nous devons tous me
semble-t-il l'accepter et plutôt écouter
ces témoignages et vous faire votre
propre opinion alors je voudrais revenir
sur un propos du rapporteur tout à
l'heure qui m'a un peu surpris va faire
un lien un peu direct un peu trop direct
entre la productivité et l'idée que si
les Français avaient une forte
productivité c'était qu'il était pas si
mal au travail c'était un drôle de un
drôle de lien tout de même je voudrais
j'ai recherché depuis quelques éléments
mais que facilement avec ça heureusement
on trouve tout alors l'enquête refende
sur les conditions de travail en Europe
qui a été réalisée qui réalisait
d'ailleurs chaque année et auprès de 71
000 personnes en 2021 mais la France en
queue de peloton parmi les 36 pays sous
vus presque 40% des actifs à l'emploi
chez nous se trouvent dans un emploi dit
tendu où les adjigences sont plus élevés
que les ressources permettant de
répondre à celle-ci et mes chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur parce
que vous avez sans doute pas lu cette
étude on est au niveau sur ces sujets là
on est au niveau de l'Albanie de la
Slovaquie de la Pologne je dis pas que
ce sont pas des exemples je me prononce
pas mais je le mets sur le débat quand
même et je pense qu'il faut arrêter de
faire ce lien un peu rapide entre
productivité et plaisir d'être au
travail
merci monsieur le Président Madame
poncémonge
merci monsieur le Président alors j'ai
bien entendu
la fébrilité de monsieur le rapporteur
qu'on a à l'article 8 très certainement
pour parler de quelques mesures que vous
proposez mais nous sommes à l'article 7
et l'article 7 il dit que la quasi
majorité des départs anticipés sont des
départs
rendus possible par la mobilisation du
C2P c'est-à-dire par par la pénibilité
et de moins en moins par les carrières
longues c'est à dire quand on a commencé
ou super long comme vous le voulez et
dans l'article enfin par l'article 7 ce
départ anticipé il est retardé de deux
ans là aussi ces deux enfermes monsieur
le rapporteur effectivement si vous avez
quelques améliorations il faut pas trop
sauter trop vite à l'article 8 pour dire
les petites mesures d'accompagnement que
vous allez faire mais déjà constater
acter les départs anticipés pour
pénibilité par deux ans plus tard quant
à la validité permanente si on a des
propositions si vous avez des
propositions pour l'instant nous sommes
d'accord rien n'a changé ils partent à
62 ans toujours dans la loi c'est pour
ça monsieur le ministre que je vous dis
que les 3 milliards que vous mettez en
mesure d'accompagnement n'ont pas lieu
d'être puisque c'est le maintien d'un
dispositif mais par contre Monsieur le
Ministre puisque vous avez fait toutes
votre équilibre financier en comptant un
dumant ces 3 milliards sans alors que
c'est maintenu je vous propose de passer
l'invalidité permanente à 60 ans auquel
cas vous pouvez remettre les 3 milliards
100 en mesure d'accompagnement merci
Monsieur Houlgate
[Musique]
conséquente à des mutations donc le
développement de l'automatisation de la
numérisation et ainsi de suite on a
commencé à parler dans le monde du
travail de risque psychosociaux et il
faut souligner que c'est la loi du 17
janvier 2002 Martine Aubry qui a
introduit la notion de santé mentale
dans le code du travail ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que d'une certaine
façon c'est une génération je veux pas
dire que c'est une génération qui a été
sacrifiée mais c'est une génération qui
a vécu une profonde mutation du monde du
travail et qui en était elle-même
profondément marquée et peut-être
peut-être un peu meurtri donc cette
génération prononce en garde moi je dans
les manifestations et on l'a retrouvé
d'ailleurs dans un article de
Ouest-France ou quelqu'un disait
peut-être à travers ce mal au travail
sur lequel on a beaucoup pris les choses
en considération mais il a dit moi ma
vie professionnelle ça a été un marathon
et bien j'ai l'impression que on a
reculé la ligne d'arrivée de ce marathon
alors on peut le déplorer il y a des
choses qui ont été faites mais faisons
attention à cette génération sacrifier
61 65 si Madame Lindman
il a il a déjà été beaucoup dit il a
déjà été beaucoup dit le problème de la
génération avec cette accélération qui
s'attendait à partir en retraite et qui
voit brutalement le mur reculé mais je
voudrais insister sur les faits sur le
niveau des pensions en accélérant les
délais de la réforme Touraine plus en
allongeant de deux ans là je les gale on
va avoir un effet sur le niveau de
pension extrêmement préoccupant puisque
dans ces simulations la pension moyenne
net passerait de 61,2 % du salaire moyen
en 2021 à
51,6 en 2050 soit
-15,7%. puis ensuite seulement à 45,4%
en 2070 soit moins
25,8%. c'est une chute brutale du niveau
de vie des retraités qui jusqu'à présent
est assez proche du niveau moyen des
revenus de les revenus des Français bien
que depuis deux trois ans c'est déjà
baissé et là on va atteindre des choses
terribles puisque on va retrouver des
retraités pauvres je vous donne les
chiffres c'est au lieu d'être à 5 ans à
égalité ce ratio ne serait donc plus de
100% mais de 89% en 2050
94% en 2070 donc de toute façon ce qui
est vrai c'est pourquoi nous avons mené
des amendements sur les recettes c'est
que dans le système actuel si on veut
rééquilibrer les retraites il y aura
quand même besoin de recettes
merci chers collègues le président
madurée de la parole merci monsieur le
Président je sur cet amendement je
demande l'application de l'article 38
1 qui avait intervenir contre ma mère
contre
sur l'application
je pense que ce soir et dans les heures
qui viennent il va falloir s'attendre à
avoir ces demandes récurrentes pour nous
empêcher pour nous empêcher d'en
véritablement dans un débat de fond un
débat sérieux toutes les interventions
qui se sont tenues jusqu'à maintenant
sont des interventions sérieuses fondées
argumenté et donc je ne vois pas vous
avez le droit effectivement d'activer au
titre du Règlement du Sénat de demander
d'activer certains articles 38 mais vous
imaginez bien que nous y sommes
totalement opposés et que là encore une
fois encore une fois vous bafouez
véritablement le rôle du Sénat c'est une
atteinte à la démocratie que d'autres et
que à l'extérieur parce qu'on nous
regarde à l'extérieur on nous regarde on
nous écoute à l'extérieur et quand on
verra que lorsqu'on s'engage sur ses
débats et sur ses environnement qui ont
été déposés absolument justifiés parce
qu'ils sont même sur le fond même et la
déclinaison très précise à
concrétisation de ce recul d'âge pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui vont
voir les conséquences dès cette année
dès l'année prochaine et non pas dans
les années à venir sur les conséquences
de cette réforme brutale de propositions
de recul d'âge merci monsieur benaroche
alors la raison c'est quoi la raison en
fait me semble-t-il mais je me trompe
peut-être il faudrait faire une étude
statistique je m'excuse vous avez
demandé l'article 38 j'ai le droit
d'exprimer ce que je pense vous n'êtes
pas obligé de le couper voilà donc je me
suis dit c'est une autre raison quelle
est cette raison et en faisant une
petite étude sur les deux fois où vous
l'avez utilisé par rapport aux fois où
vous l'avez pas utilisé on verra si
c'est confirmé par l'effet dans le futur
il me semble en fait que vous l'utilisez
mais peut-être me trompe à partir du
moment où vous estimez que le débat
devient suffisamment intéressant et a pu
à certains ordre d'arguments auxquels
vous ne souhaitez par répondre puisque
vous ne voulez pas prolonger le débat
vous avez les réponses vraisemblablement
je suis persuadé que vous avez des
réponses pour argumenter contre les
arguments qui ont été proposés mais vous
ne pouvez pas les donner puisque c'est
votre règle ne pourra pas les données
vous décidez d'écourter le débat parce
qu'il est argumenté et vous les courtez
effectivement en posant l'article 38 si
je me trompe dites-le moi chers amis
mais je pense que je suis dans le vrai
si chers collègues madame Lindeman
chers collègues on pouvait pas dire que
le débat qui était engagé sur ce sujet
était pas un débat intéressant parce
qu'on était au cœur du débat sur le
niveau des pensions
du débat sur le l'effet de seuil de
changement qui est toujours un problème
politique pour tout le monde quand il y
a une réforme et là bâclé le discussions
bâcler les effets de réflexion alors
vous savez qu'est-ce que ça révèle chers
collègues quand on est embarrassé quand
on sait qu'on est en décalage avec le
peuple et ben on essaie de faire ça vite
fait ni vu ni connu à la sauvette alors
comme Monsieur Macron quand les amis de
Lorraine nous explique il faut aller
plus vite on a l'habitude chers
collègues ils passent son temps à nous
dire qu'il y a trop de parlementaires
que le Parlement ça va trop vite qu'on
fait toujours des procédures d'urgence à
la limite je dirais c'est leur culture
de contournement du parle mais vous la
majorité sénatoriale elle est a priori
ça ne devrait pas être votre culture
alors que vous soyez un peu agacé parce
que nous avons la force de nos arguments
je peux le comprendre mais vous devriez
comprendre que nos concitoyens attendent
de vous des explications des réponses à
nos arguments de faire entretenir le
débat mais vous avez peur de l'opinion
publique vous ne vous sentez pas fort
pour les renforcer et sa justifie votre
votre stratégie décourtez le débat merci
cher collègue donc je vais mettre aux
voix l'application de l'article 38 qui a
été demandé qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient donc l'article 38
s'applique et donc nous allons passer au
vote j'étais saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe CRCE sur
cet amendement 4286 avec deux avis
défavorables
le scrutin est ouvert
les sénateurs qui continuent à voter sur
des scrutins publiques concernant des
amendements déposés par la gauche sur
cet article 7 article majeur de cette
réforme des retraites articles qui
reporte progressivement légal de départ
à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans et un
article qui est également accéléré
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
pour atteindre 43 annuités en 2027 on
écoute le résultat de ce scooter en
public
alors on ouvre le scrutin
ce que tu as est à nouveau ouvert
c'est un clou
donc le scrutin est clos
nombre de votants 344 exprimé 343 pour
93 contre 250 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous passons à trois amendements
identiques le 1895 la présidente de
Lattre oui merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues l'article
l3514-1 du code de la sécurité sociale
créé par la réforme des retraites de
2003 prévoit un mécanisme de rachat
d'année d'études pour les assurer
salariés depuis 2003 les assurés peuvent
donc ainsi racheter jusqu'à 12
trimestres d'assurance vieillesse au
titre des années d'études supérieur le
tarif du rachat qui varie selon l'âge et
le niveau de revenu et déterminé selon
un principe de neutralité actuelle c'est
à dire qu'il pèse intégralement sur son
bénéficiaire si ce versement est pris en
compte dans le calcul d'une retraite
classique les trimestres ainsi rachetés
ne sont pas retenus dans le cadre de
dispositifs de retraite anticipée pour
carrière longue ou pour les travailleurs
handicapés il nous faut donc corriger ce
point tout comme le mécanisme mis en
place par la réforme des retraites de
2014 qui a établi un tarif préférentiel
de rachat trimestre pour certains
assurés notamment les apprentis au titre
des périodes d'apprentissage du 1er
juillet 1972 au 31 décembre 2013 car il
cotisait sur une assiette forfaitaire
trop faible pour leur permettre de
valider une durée d'assurance vieillesse
égale à celle de leur contrat nous
souhaiterions donc que les assurer ne
soient pas pénalisés par l'absence de
prise en compte de ces versements dans
le cadre d'un départ anticipé pour
carrière longue ou en tant que
travailleur handicapés aussi nous
proposons que ces versements soient
désormais pris en compte tant dans la
période cotisée que pour apprécier la
condition de début d'activité au titre
du dispositif de retraite pour carrière
longue je vous remercie
de 1909 identique monsieur lévrier
merci monsieur le Président comme ça a
été indiqué précédemment c'est
amendement visa permettre la prise en
compte dans le cadre d'un départ
anticipé pour carrière longue ou en tant
que travailleur handicapé les trimestres
d'apprentissage effectués avant 2014 et
racheté à tarif réduit c'est pour nous
une question de justice sociale que
d'assurer que tous les citoyens ayant eu
un statut d'apprenti puisse obtenir
l'avantage de leur trimestre
d'apprentissage et parce que je crois
profondément à l'apprentissage que je
crois profondément à ces jeunes qui
choisissent cette filière et tout
particulièrement à ceux qui ont subi des
accidents de la vie c'est pourquoi je
tiens à vous présenter cet amendement
déjà porté à l'Assemblée nationale et
qu'il me tient particulièrement à cœur
je vous remercie et le 3403 identique
madame pour ces Monges
oui monsieur le président
en préalable je tiens exprimer mon
émotion
pour défendre un des 17 amendements qui
ont survécu
après le sous-amendement je ne parle
même pas de ceux qui n'avaient même pas
survécu
à lire ça valabilité en commission dans
un premier temps mais j'avais 157
amendements qui avaient trouvé qui était
paraît-il recevable et il s'en est plus
que 17 donc c'est un grand moment
d'émotion
donc bon je peux pas mettre cette
digression parce que c'est un petit peu
la même chose donc l'article 27 de la
loi du 20 janvier 2014 qui a ouvert la
possibilité pour certaines catégories
d'assurer par dérogation aux principes
de neutralité actuelle de bénéficier
d'une diminution du coût de leur
versement c'est notamment le cas vous
l'avez dit pour les apprentis dont le
nombre a récemment explosé comme vous le
savez tous fin 2022 la DARES sont
dénombrées 980 000 soit près d'un
million il faut bien préciser qu'il faut
l'essentiel de l'amélioration des
statistiques de l'emploi avec les
radiations mais c'est un autre mécanisme
donc il faut donc pouvoir garantir à ses
assurés qui ne soient pas pénalisés par
l'absence de prise en compte des
versements évoqués
dans le cas et notamment dans le cas
effectivement d'un départ anticipés pour
carrière longue ou en tant que
travailleur handicapé le contraire
serait injuste d'autant que précisément
leur carrière commence très tôt en
conséquence notre amendement vise ce que
ces derniers soient désormais prise en
compte dans la période cotisée les
rendants par ce fait éligibles au titre
du dispositif de retraite pour carrière
longue il s'agit donc enfin d'une mesure
de justice et d'une mesure de bon sens
[Musique]
oui merci d'avoir effectivement
poser ses amendements parce que il y
avait
une anomalie quand même que ces
trimestres
justement d'apprenti soit pas pris en
compte à la fois dans la durée mais
aussi dans le calcul derrière de la
carrière et notamment pour les carrières
longues
véritablement la carrière longue sévère
les apprentis que c'est décidé ceux qui
commencent de bonheur c'est pas pour
ceux qui sont me semble-t-il plus loin
il se rapporte d'un dispositif commun
vraiment de 16-18 ans c'est 15 même 15
18 ans c'est vraiment là qu'on a besoin
de prendre en compte les apprentis et
donc
ça montre bien la différence mes chers
collègues de calcul entre la carrière
longue on prend que les trimestres
cotisées ou réputés cotisés dans le
calcul des 43 ans qu'il y aura à faire
mais 43 ans sur une carrière normale
il faudra qu'on en parle c'est pas une
carrière longue c'est la carrière
normale maintenant et les 43 ans pour
les autres qui s'appliquent après à
partir de 20 ans ou à l'intérieur de ces
43 ans vous avez les trimestres cotisés
réputés cotisées assimilés et les
majorations de pension quand il s'agit
de mère de famille donc on voit bien
qu'il y a une différence de traitement
mais il était nécessaire merci monsieur
le ministre d'avoir aussi la même
réflexion il était nécessaire de le
prendre en compte je vous réponds bien
volontiers parce que ça ça répond de
l'article 7 les questions précédentes
Raymond de poser le sais bien quand même
le C2P c'est pas certain article là et
Madame Liman elle sait bien aussi que
les petites pensions c'est l'article 10
donc les réponses on les fera en
fonction des articles si on arrive à
clarifier ce débat comme ça je pense
qu'on peut éviter de sortir l'article 38
non donc on clarifie le débat et on fait
en sorte que les questions qui se posent
elles disposent au bon moment si vous en
êtes d'accord bien entendu donc
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
d'amendement identique un amendement
déposé par la député Christine
ledimbourg qui n'a pas pu être examiné à
l'Assemblée et comme ce qui a été dit
par les différents intervenants cela va
permettre d'intégrer dans les périodes
prises en compte pour l'éligibilité au
départ anticipé au titre des carrières
longues les trimestres effectués en
apprentissage et tout particulièrement
ceux qui ont fait l'objet d'un rachat de
trimestre au tarif préférentiels qui
sont prévus pour les rachats trimestre
donc c'est une mesure du de justice et
le gouvernement il est favorable et
Monsieur le GAT
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues puisqu'on en
est au stade des questions moi j'ai une
question à poser à René Paul Savary
puisqu'on parle beaucoup des des
apprentis et à juste titre donc les
apprentis sont concernés mais il y a
d'autres catégories et notamment il y a
une catégorie moi qui me touche
particulière ment c'est ceux qu'on
appelle les aides familiaux et ces aides
familiaux on les retrouve dans deux
secteurs dans le secteur agricole il y a
eu énormément d'aide familiaux agricoles
dans ce domaine et puis bien évidemment
dans le domaine du commerce également où
on a vu bien souvent des enfants de
commerçants qui d'une certaine façon
avant de reprendre l'activité parentale
était dans des conditions qui sont
souvent un peu floues qui qui apportait
donc une aide donc à la tenue à la tenue
du commerce donc est-ce que ces aides
familiaux à partir du moment où comment
dirais-je leur activité professionnelle
serait reconnue en termes de trimestre
on la possibilité puisque souvent ils
n'ont pas été couverts par une
cotisation de pouvoir procéder à le
rachat parce que c'est la gamme qu'on
emploie au rachat de de ces trimestres
trouve ses amendements intéressants même
si bon il est quand même question de
rachat de trimestre et on sait que les
rachats de trimestres coûtent cher mais
bon
c'est une fenêtre me semble-t-il
intéressante monsieur le rapporteur je
vous prends au mot
monsieur le rapporteur je vous prends au
mot
je vous prends au mot effectivement sur
des amendements de fonds voilà on peut
discuter et donc on discute c'est à dire
que si même on débarque pardon on débat
et donc et donc comme je vous prends moi
je vous le dis sur des amendements comme
celui-là et comme celui de tout à
l'heure mon amendement sur l'histoire
des 5% de surcotes je ne comprends
décidément pas pourquoi l'article 38 a
été déployé parce qu'on était vraiment
sur le fond là aussi sur le sujet
ces trois amendements identiques
notre groupe votre alamondement déposé
par notre collègue
lévrier nous pensons que c'est une
avancée et puisque souvent nous explique
qu'il faut augmenter qu'en augmentant
les cotisations on allait nuire à
l'emploi et à la compositivité des
entreprises comme si la baisse des
cotisations était le fin du fin de la
création d'emplois je vous rappellerai
que dans les échos de juin 2022 il nous
est bien expliqué que dans l'année 2022
il est a priori et ça a été confirmé
d'ailleurs après que les deux tiers des
200 000 emplois créés dit dans le privé
l'ont été en apprentissage et donc c'est
moins la baisse des cotisations que le
soutien donné à des emplois pour former
des jeunes générations qui aura résolu
ou en tout cas baisser le niveau du
chômage nous nous soutenons en tout cas
cet amendement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mes chers collègues simplement
pour m'étonner un peu de
décrocher des ici maintenant sur
l'utilisation de l'article 38 là aussi
il suffira de revoir finalement ce qui
se passe dans cette assemblée pour se
rendre compte que ça fait un moment
qu'on est pour pas dire depuis toujours
sur le fond mais
c'est Savary vous avez une pratique
amusante sympathique je me souviens que
depuis l'article 2 à l'article 2 vous
nous dites mais
avançons avançons parce que on va
traiter les sujets et on va les traiter
notamment à l'article 7 en disant tout
ça faut aller vite faut aller vite faut
aller à l'article 7 et maintenant que
nous sommes à l'article 7 vous nous
dites pour aller vite il faut aller à
l'article 8 bon voilà il y a une espèce
de de côté comme ça systématique nous
renvoyons nous renvoyant en permanence
au sujet d'après quoi voilà donc je
voulais je voulais vous dire je voulais
vous dire que ce procédé il faudrait
maintenant l'arrêter je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que vous avez fait vous êtes
fait un honneur d'ouvrir très largement
plus qu'à l'Assemblée le temps de
discussion alors il faut quand même
maintenant l'utiliser ah voilà c'est pas
la peine c'est pas la peine d'avoir
annoncé on travaille jusqu'à dimanche
soir pour mon accélérer trop vite et se
retrouver je sais pas désemparé vendredi
par exemple donc tenez
votre parole il faut aller au dimanche
soir on doit aller au dimanche soir
allons-y calmement et enfin dernier mot
je voudrais quand même féliciter notre
collègue pensez mange je crois qu'on
peut le faire parce que c'est le premier
amendement de cette partie de
l'hémicycle qui est bientôt je le crois
accepter on peut applaudir
merci chers collègues
le président
monsieur le Président je ne me connais
pas la force d'un certain nombre
d'arguments qui viennent de nous être
présentés
je suis moi-même un passionné de
l'apprentissage
et je considère qu'il est essentiel dans
notre pays que les jeunes
adoptent cette disposition d'esprit
essentielle qui consiste à choisir ses
études en vue du métier et à faire
l'apprentissage du métier en situation
de travail pour autant il me semble que
cet amendement dans la rédaction est
approximative
n'a pas été suffisamment étudié et en ce
qui me concerne je voterai donc contre
cet amendement et je suggère à tous mes
collègues de s'y opposer je m'y
opposerai en tout cas fermement jusqu'à
ce qu'on est plus faire avancer la
discussion pour améliorer le contenu de
ce genre d'initiative
bon je vais je vais mettre au bois à
monsieur le ministre vous ayez
merci monsieur le Président juste un mot
pour répondre aux interrogations de
Madame Lubin et s'il me le permet de
répondre et de dire un mot aux questions
bas d'abord pour dire que Madame Liban
ne m'écoute pas d'abord dire à Madame
Dubin que le dispositif pour ce qui
concerne l'apprentissage fait que les
trimestres travaillent en apprentissage
sont comptés comme cotisés depuis 2013
parce que la rémunération des apprentis
a atteint un niveau qui permet de les
compter il a été prévu dans la loi 2013
applicable à partir 2014 la possibilité
d'un rachat rachat autour de 1500 euros
le trimestre ça peut paraître beaucoup
comme ça mais cela deux caractéristiques
c'est une somme fixe pendant toute la
carrière alors que tous les rachats de
trimestres sont fondés sur une somme qui
tient compte d'une méthode actuelle et
qui peuvent atteindre 5 à 6000 euros si
on les rachète à la toute fin de la
carrière donc je dis que ça avantageux
parce que la somme fixe de 1500 euros
est valable tout au long de la carrière
par contre la prise en compte de ces
trimestres rachetés étaient prévus pour
ce qui concerne la durée de cotisation
requise pour avoir accès à une retraite
à taux plein sans décote mais pas pour
l'éligibilité au départ au titre des
carrières longues et donc ce que nous
faisons avec cet amendement ce qui est
proposé par les parlementaires en tout
cas c'est de permettre l'accès aux
dispositif de départ de carrière longue
sur la base de citron
ne changeons rien aux conditions de
rachat de 2014 et pour dire à Monsieur
le questerba que que je tiens rassuré
monsieur le kesterba il s'agit vraiment
d'intégrer donc ces trimestres rachetés
alors qu'ils ont été réalisés dans le
cas d'un contrat d'apprentissage qui
n'était pas suffisamment rémunéré pour
être considéré comme cotisé dans le
cadre des trimestres retenus pour
l'éligibilité au départ entier pour les
carrières longues vous interrogez sur sa
rédaction je peux vous assurer monsieur
le Kester que la rédaction proposée par
le parlementaires reçoit la probation
complète des du gouvernement
merci
la parole est au président malgré
merci monsieur le Président il a eu sur
cet amendement plusieurs orateurs qui
l'ont défendu un orateur qui s'est
exprimé contre le ministre et le
rapporteur se sont longuement exprimés
sur cette abonnement je demande donc
l'application de l'article 38 merci
je suis saisi donc sur cette amendement
de l'application d'article 38 le
président Gontard
merci
merci Monsieur le merci monsieur le
Président je suis je suis heureux que le
président malloret est enfin trouvé le
livre vert mais franchement franchement
l'article 48 ok vous avez fait une
découverte depuis hier soir ça c'est
rigolo 5 minutes mais quand même on est
en train de débattre sur des amendements
RDSE RDPI écologiste on est en train de
d'échanger
même il me semble que Monsieur
rapporteur a dit que c'était intéressant
on a eu des vrais des vrais échanges
même le président bat aussi a intervenu
il me semble pour dire d'ailleurs les
doutes qui pouvaient avoir sur cet
amendement donc il me semble quand même
que ces échanges qu'on a eu ils sont
plus utiles ils sont plus
qu'intéressants donc moi je suis quand
même déjà sur l'usage de l'article 38
comme vous le faites depuis hier soir
qui est totalement scandaleux mais le
faire de cette manière là sur des
amendements sur lequel on est dans une
discussion qu'est-ce qui change par
rapport
à notre habitude et notre habitude qu'on
a ici de débattre de manière sereine
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui vous
énerve aujourd'hui pourquoi vous ne
voulez plus débattre qu'est-ce qui vous
qu'est-ce qui vous gêne dans cet article
7 quelle est cette obstruction quasi
continuelle ça y est Monsieur monsieur
Manu et a trouvé son livre vert et
maintenant il va nous faire des articles
38 après article 38 c'est quand même
enfin comme donc franchement je pense
que vous pourriez encore retirer qu'on
puisse débattre et sereinement pouvoir
voter pour pouvoir voter ses amendements
qui me semble important en plus on l'a
dit c'était peut-être le seul amendement
de cette partie là de l'hémicie qui
pouvait être qui pouvait venir peut-être
quelque peu enrichir ce texte quand même
et en plus c'était un amendement de
Raymonde pourcemonge qui quand même n'a
pas ménagé sa peine depuis le début de
ce
depuis le début de ce débats
merci monsieur jaumier
merci
monsieur le président
malgré
nous avons tous constaté que sur ces
trois amendements il y a eu des échanges
qui était il me semble terminé le
ministre s'est exprimé et je crois sauf
erreur qu'il n'y avait plus de demande
de parole
votre déclenchement de l'article 38
amène chacun des groupes de l'opposition
maintenant à s'exprimer pendant le temps
qu'il aurait dévolu pour vous faire
remarquer que vous êtes en train de
tourner en ridicule l'application de cet
article vous êtes en train de le tourner
en ridicule
il n'y avait vous ne pouvez pas vous ne
pouvez pas arguer de la moindre
obstruction à l'occasion de c'est la
discussion de ces amendements à
l'occasion de la discussion de ces
amendements donc si vous êtes parti pour
appliquer l'article 38 sur chaque
amendement sur chaque amendement il va y
avoir des prises de parole de nos trois
groupes pour pointer le fait que
pour pointer le fait que vous êtes dans
une application indiscriminée qui vise à
faire obstacle à la conduite des débats
moi j'appelle mais vraiment je vous
appelle à ne pas voter l'application
l'article 38 sur cette sésamendement là
et vous verrez qu'il n'y aura pas une
pluie d'intervention que en gros le
débat est épuisé il y aura peut-être un
collègue ou je ne sais pas ou deux qui
s'exprimera je n'en sais rien non nous
avons eu un débat apaisé et intéressant
le ministre a apporté des éléments qui
étaient intéressants et si vous ne
voulez pas de ce type de discussion
alors effectivement nous allons passer
quatre jours à des interventions
purement sur la forme qui vont là
n'avoir aucun intérêt vous avez la
responsabilité vous avez la majorité
vous avez des armes du règlement vous
avez aussi la responsabilité que la
conduite des débats soit apaisée merci
chers collègues madame Brulat
merci monsieur le Président je suis un
peu frappé que notre collègue m'a lu ré
qui donne des leçons de démocratie à la
terre entière
soit choquée que chacun puisse défendre
ici quelques amendements je trouve que
le débat qui vient de s'engager
était d'un apport au débat global parce
que c'est la première fois à ma
connaissance que nous a que nous
abordons ce sujet de l'apprentissage moi
j'ai été particulièrement intéressé
d'entendre l'argumentation du de
Philippe Bas et je pense que ce sujet
mérite d'être approfondi
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que
l'Assemblée nationale détient désormais
le record de du nombre de 49,3 qui ont
été appliqués je crois qu'on en est déjà
11 est-ce que le Sénat veut s'engager
dans une concurrence
où il activeait l'article 38 bien
davantage encore j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire tout à l'heure j'ai entendu
pique pendre ici et parfois pour de très
bonnes raisons de la manière dont
c'était déroulé le débat à l'Assemblée
nationale
il faudrait pas me semble-t-il que ce
qui ressorte c'est que l'image du Sénat
donne la même mais si si mes chers
collègues si mes chers collègues c'est
l'image qui va rester parce que vous
savez nos concitoyens ils ne sont pas
férus comme vous de des articles du
règlement intérieur du Sénat ils sont
férus de débats démocratiques sur sur un
sujet qui engage leur vie et donc vos
procédures et vos manœuvres ils n'en ont
que faire ils veulent que nous
argumentions et que nous défendions les
uns et les autres comme il est légitime
de le faire nos options nos projets de
société sur des sujets aussi précis et
utiles que l'apprentissage merci chers
collègues même la présidence de Delattre
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le Président je ne
prendrais pas la parole sur la réplique
38 mais je voulais saluer la vie
favorable de la commission et sortir un
peu de ce débat stérile parce que je
pense que le RDSE n'est pas dans une
manœuvre d'obstruction mais nous avons
rendu peu d'amendements et quand ils le
sont c'est vraiment pour améliorer nos
articles nous sommes regardés par
beaucoup de personnes concernées par cet
article et cet amendement spécifiquement
nous avons été sensibilité par
sensibilisé par beaucoup d'associations
de personnes handicapées qui sont
concernées par ces amendements donc
j'aimerais que cet amendement ne soit
pas pris en otage
mais vraiment que nous puissions en âme
et conscience le voter parce que c'est
une mesure juste et au Sénat nous savons
peser sur ces mesures justes donc chers
collègues je vous demanderai
effectivement de pouvoir suivre
la vie favorable de la commission merci
merci chers collègues monsieur le
Président Retailleau
ce qu'a proposé Bernard jaumier c'était
très intéressant il a proposé que une
sorte d'antan pour qu'on aurait on
aurait pu se concentrer avec l'accord de
l'ensemble des groupes
sur ce qui constitue le cœur de la
réforme sur ce qui constitue l'essentiel
de nos intérêts c'est ce que le
président gérarchez vous après vous a
proposé ce matin juste avant la
conférence des présidents messieurs les
présidents de groupes de gauche et vous
avez refusé parce que vous voulez faire
une obstruction parce que vous voulez
que le Parlement de vote pas
l'obstruction c'est un parlement qui se
fait Hara-Kiri l'obstruction c'est la
négation du parlementarisme
l'obstruction c'est une prise en otage
d'une minorité sur l'ensemble de
l'institution
si et nous vous nous obliger à recourir
à l'article 38 si chacun est raisonnable
si chacun discute au fond des articles
sans volonté d'obstruction alors oui
chacun pourra jouer le jeu mais la balle
est de votre camp écoutez j'ai
11 amendements vous voulez que vous
voulez que je les lisse et 11
amendements
4769 70 71 des amendements d'obstruction
et j'en ai d'autres par dizaines et par
centaines c'est ce que les Français
doivent savoir donc le 38 il est fait
pour neutraliser une manœuvre
d'obstruction la manœuvre d'obstruction
c'est la négation du rôle du Parlement
merci chers collègues
la parole est au président patriar
[Applaudissements]
non non
j'écoute avec attention son vociférer
sans interrompre et en essayant de
laisser l'opposition s'exprimer le plus
longtemps possible avec beaucoup de
patience et avec beaucoup d'accuités je
le dis mais par contre il y a une chose
que je supporte pas mes chers collègues
c'est l'hypocrisie parce que
l'hypocrisie ça consiste à dire ici on
veut débattre de l'apprentissage moi
l'apprentissage c'est un sujet qui me
passionne les sujets qu'on aborde
maintenant son passionnant qu'on puisse
en débattre oui mais le problème pour
vous c'est pas de débattre le débattre
c'est le faux prétexte parce que ce
matin j'étais en conférence des
présidents et j'ai entendu les trois
présidents des groupes d'opposition dire
clairement qu'il ne voulait pas qu'on
vote le texte au beau et ils l'ont dit
et ils l'ont dit donc nous faire croire
aujourd'hui qu'on veut débattre plus
qu'on veut toujours débattre plus tout
ça en fin de compte le débat plus il est
uniquement pour atteindre l'objectif
sont donnés celui de ne pas voter ce
texte se dessaisir se dessaisir de
pouvoir de voter la loi trouve sa
parfaitement hyp je le dénonce
merci cher collègue
donc je vais mettre aux voix
l'application de l'article 38 qui est
pour l'application de l'article 38
qui est contre
qui s'abstient donc l'article 38 est
adopté donc va être appliqué et donc
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe
écologiste sur les amendements
identiques 1895 1909 et 3403 avec deux
avis favorables il va être procédé donc
au scrutin public le scrutin est ouvert
voilà avec ce scrutin public que vous
vivez en direct sur l'antenne de public
c'est un public sur des amendements
concernant la prise en compte des années
d'apprentissage dans les carrières
effectivement pour cotiser et on voit ce
faux rythme qui se dessine avec des
discussions sur le fond de ces trois
amendements qui venaient du RDSE qui
venait également enduire des pays et
également des écologistes et ensuite et
bien une prise de parole qui s'est
enchaînée sur les l'utilité ou pas de
l'article 38 qui vient contraindre les
débats et un quatrième utilisation de
cet articles 38 effectivement dans
l'hémicycle
344 contre 0 le Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
alors des amendements identiques
et en discussion commune trois
amendements identiques tout d'abord le
Sénat vient de voter un amendement dans
l'article 7 de la réforme des retraites
un article un amendement qui comme le
disait Quentin concerne notamment les
personnes qui ont fait de
l'apprentissage les trimestres rachetés
correspondant à ces périodes
d'apprentissage pourront être désormais
avec cet amendement pris en compte dans
le calcul du dispositif carrière long
voilà ça vient d'être voté par le Sénat
aussi pour compenser cette situation un
dispositif de validation de trimestre a
été mis en place en 2012 pour les
sportifs qui sont inscrits sur la liste
des sportifs de haut niveau le nombre de
trimestres maximales qui peut ainsi être
acquis et limité à 16 soit 4 ans ce qui
correspond à une olympiade avec cette
amendement on vise à porter ce nombre
maximal de validation de trimestre à 32
soit 2 Olympiades et par ailleurs il
ouvre également la possibilité sportive
de haut niveau de racheter des périodes
antérieures à 2012 ou des périodes
postérieure à 2012
merci monsieur le Président je pense que
c'est amendement devrait aussi faire
l'unanimité dans cette hémicycle et
comme le rappeler Claude quai donc cet
objectif c'est de permettre aux sportifs
au niveau inscrit sur les listes et
ministérielles de pouvoir donc étendre
ce dispositif à 32 trimestres nous en
réjouissons il sera ainsi plus adapté la
durée moyenne des carrières sportives
c'est un moment propose également bien
sûr d'ouvrir pour ses athlètes le rachat
de trimestre et c'est une bonne avance
par contre Monsieur le Ministre tous les
athlètes ne sont pas concernés par cette
mesure et certains qui ont jeunes femmes
et hommes qui ont brillé février les
couleurs de la France sur les différents
terrains lors des compétitions
olympiques et des championnats du monde
ne bénéficie pas de ce dispositif je
parle de tous ceux qui étaient avant la
réforme de 2012 donc aujourd'hui nous
avons toute une série d'athlètes qui se
retrouvent
sur la réforme des retraites notamment
sur l'article 7 qui est reporte l'âge
légal de départ à 64 c'est la fin de
cette émission spéciale merci à Quentin
à calmer dans la tribune de l'hémicycle
d'avoir commenté ces débats rendez-vous
à 22h justement avec Quentin Calmet pour
suivre la suite des échanges autour de
cet article 7 article essentiel de la
réforme des retraites très bonne soirée
sur Public Sénat
[Musique]